Ừ ừ
hôm nay về sớm sớm hơn mọi hôm một tí
thì
mà mày Hà Nội mưa gió là tôi nghĩa gạo
lên công ty buổi sáng xong rồi chưa ăn
xong hơi bị buồn ngủ tí xong rồi
ngồi trên công ty làm không tập trung
được mà cả thôi nghĩa cũng phải về sớm
ngày mai dậy nha không ai quyết định ở
nhà là đi ra là ngày mày với ngày ngày
được phép làm thế
và bạn cả sinh hoạt nó cũng hơi bị dở
dang ví tiền hình sợ hôm nay có nhiều
bạn hãy tôi Cậu đang đang 6 giờ sáng
người đang thông báo thực tế là tôi dậy
lúc 3 giờ sáng rồi Tôi vừa làm việc cơ
Ai Những ngành khác thì ông không được
như thế Ngay khác và xử mà ông ngủ nhớ
bữa như thế thằng Nhạn nó ngon ông vậy
cố thức đến giờ nào đó rồi bia làm chỉ
cần tôi cảm thấy tôi được phải mãi mãi
kiểu cảm nhận là có nhiều lúc thì vẫn
phải căng theo kiểu là có vấn đề gì thì
đúng là mình phải dậy để mà
dậy bật dậy để mà làm việc nếu mà có lỗi
vấn đề gì đó Cái đấy thì thử Tôi thấy
thực ra đa số ngày nào nó cũng thế Nếu
là không phải giờ hành chính có ngoài
giờ là mình nhưng mà có vấn đề được nghe
Mình phải giải quyết ông ạ nhưng mà còn
đâu Thời gian khác thoải mái
những kiểu sếp thì cũng ngày nào cũng có
thể ra bọn tôi Ngày nào cũng họp Nhưng
nói thật là
mang tiếng ngày nào cũng họp với báo cáo
mình đã làm những gì nhưng nhưng mà có
thể Ông cứ luôn hẹp Tí và thực là sẽ
cũng biết mà phải trông vào cậu không
phải ngày nào cũng bị gì hết like gì cả
Vẫn là thoải mái
không ạ Ừ nếu mà so với hồi mà tôi đi
dạy thì đúng là mẹ tôi thích hồi nhưng
tôi đi dạy hơn nhất là các bà mẹ mà vẫn
ngoài điểm con làm giảng viên gì không
xong rồi lương cao nó cả tôi được sinh
hoạt nó vẫn tử tế hơn so bây giờ được
nhưng mà
và nó ổn định nữa Cái kiểu thế à
thế nhưng bù lại thì bây giờ tôi ở nhà
thằng ai với mẹ thì mẹ vợ ngỏ ý kiến gì
nữa
mẹ lo ăn lo ăn cho được cái thứ tôi được
mẹ chăm Dạo này có béo lên rồi thì chỉ
có đúng kiểu dạng là
dậy làm việc một tí rồi ăn Sao ngồi buồn
ngủ thì ngủ cá cứ thứ tăng lên được vài
cân mẹ rồi vui rồi đấy ạ
Ừ để tranh thủ tâm sự một tí trước thì
bắt đầu vào bài học nhá Đang cả là hôm
nay cô ấy buổi không phải cuối buổi đâu
tí thôi phân tích xong sớm thì sẽ là mà
tôi vừa nãy tôi lên topcv mò xem có cái
gì vì hôm nay cũng vừa có một bên VTC
academy có
hai lần người ta gọi cho tôi không được
là tìm được Facebook tôi để mà cái bạn
luôn thì để mà mời tôi về lại nơi tôi
mới biết được hóa ra ngay đậu phụ nữa
tôi tiện vết
nhưng mà tôi
vì tội mạng khá cân nhắc bởi vì à
Ẩm Thực ra tôi không hẳn là hướng đến
các công ty to không cần nhất thiết phải
cực kỳ to Tôi mới muốn về nhiều người sẽ
rất thích kiểu công ty của dại như
Google cái tên gì đó công ty rất là to
thì ngoài cái thứ nhưng mà những công tư
công ty to đấy gồm như tôi tôi từng kẻ
mấy ông Cái vụ mà cựu nhân viên Google
chia sẻ đi à Thì cựu nhân viên của FPT
nó cũng thế lần như thế nghĩa là sao
những khi ông và những công ty to ông đã
có kem ông vào vì cái mác của nó thì ông
sẽ ngại ra khi mà bị mất cái mác đấy gần
như thế à
Ừ Nó là kiểu dạo này kiểu ở
ông ông không dám nói thật lòng hỏi Vân
Ông ông bị hạn chế kiểu dạng là phát
triển ông ông không được chỉnh sửa cái
gì cả Có nhiều cái mà kiểu ông phải theo
nó ông không phải Rập khuôn như nó ông
không được tự ý làm theo thứ mình muốn
Vân Cho dù tôi định về bên FPT
academy và FA với tevez thì tôi cũng sẽ
định dạy theo phong cách của tôi tôi sẽ
dậy theo kiểu như này và theo cái cũng
chưa nhìn nó dạo của tôi tôi anh nói thế
Ngay từ đầu đó là tôi sẽ dậy p tôi không
dậy Java Đông Dậy bao giờ ngôn ngữ khác
rồi Có thể tôi biết ngôn ngữ khác cũng
không dậy nổi dậy FTP theo phong cách
của tôi mà theo cái quý bà tôi sẽ chuẩn
bị giáo án hay nói chung mà mọi thứ Ừ
tôi bà sẽ cam kết đầu ra cho họ nhưng mà
nói chung Tôi sẽ không theo format của
ai Nếu mà ai mà thực ra nghe thấy bảo
thù lý nhóm mà ý rồi à à
khi
người ra người ta mà kiểu có một cái
khuôn là đóng Tôi không thích sẽ hiểu
không theo họ đó
sau khi mà Ông làm không vì đồng lương
gần như thế và ông làm thì cái tâm của
ông ấy Ông có được phép nói Mạnh mồm
những cái điều đấy mấy ông hiểu chứ
không là sử mà ông ông làm vì tiền này
ông làm gì kiểu thiếu việc làm Vân như
thế ông dậy không dám Mạnh mồm như thế
không dám đề cử sẽ còn phải còn cậu chưa
về Làm kiểu đã bảo tao chỉ theo cách gọi
tao mày không thì thôi không có kiểu như
thế được đúng ạ đấy
Ừ nếu được nghỉ em nếu không làm gì nếu
mà ông làm thực sự vì cái tâm của ông ấy
ông sẽ sẵn sàng lên tiếng khi mà có vấn
đề gì đó ông ạ Còn khi ông làm cái tiền
đấy ạ Mình tiền cao em ạ mình không dám
làm phật lòng họ nó cậu không lên đi đấy
à Còn bây giờ mình làm thì cái tầm mình
thì mình thích Làm gì mà đấy
thôi chốt là xe đạp trợ lực ông ạ bởi vì
à thứ mà tôi không ngại đi xe đã hỏi
chưa dùng đi xa mà không sao cả đi 10
cây thanh lại được những cái quan trọng
mà rất nhiều lúc kiểu Ừ tôi kiểu có tính
hay hứng lên làm cái gì đó để đang đi
trên đường tự nhiên và rụng cái đấy tiền
thì ra nhắn tin nhắn qua đón em anh nhé
Tự nhiên sẽ
đau sẽ về rồi lấy xe máy sa cái hư hư
vân
cho mình giải phóng Hải Phòng ạ tôi Tôi
không thích đồ Apple nó sẽ dùng ở del
chưa này đều khá nhiều nhiều từng dùng
HP hay Asus gì đấy
Ừ cái video ảnh lựa chọn tâm sự mày bỏ
qua đi
138 được rồi như thế tôi tranh thủ ở
em tâm sự một tí về cái mà hộ tôi nghĩa
là tôi từng nói mấy ông rồi mà chắc là
tôi nhắc lại một lần nữa ờ
ý là tôi đã từng bảo mày ông hả mày ông
không nên so sánh bản thân mình với ai
cả nó so sánh bạn bản thân với chính
mình không ạ là cơ Mỗi ngày trôi qua mà
bạn không Mỗi ngày nói cùng hơi quá
Nhưng có tâm đạt cùng mốt ở 3 4 tháng gì
đó ông mà cảm thấy Bây giờ ông khá hơn
so với 34 tháng trước hả tiếng nó bị vấn
đề thiếu bị vọng lại
Ừ ông nào có bị đấy
ừ ừ
anh alo
YouTube cũng
ờ
ờ thì ông so sánh mình với mình với
chính mình
ở tầm 3 buồn Hồi trước đúng ạ Nó có cái
chương trình Vượt Lên Chính Mình mày
không ạ nữa không cần bằng kiểu giỏ Lang
thành công hơn nay ông cứ so sánh mình
với với hồi trước thì
em hiểu anh sẽ thấy mình khá hơn thì
mang đi đúng
tôi không biết mấy ông như nào Nhưng mà
tôi thường Ai làm như thế và thế nên là
dần dần người xung quanh tôi bảo tôi
thay đổi
Ừ không hẳn là thay đổi nhiều lắm chắc
chắn à lần nào kiểu sau 3 buồn tháng
kiểu tôi đã bị tôi Tôi Và thậm chí tôi ở
trong nhà nữa nó bảo buồn lắm không gặp
này đã bảo tung người khác khác ở đây
khác thì giờ tốt không phải khác kiểu
mày trở thành con người khác không phải
cái bản chất của tôi tôi vẫn giữ thế
giới mạnh thế nó sẽ yêu em ạ nhưng mà
khác ở đây ám chỉ kiểu dụ béo lên này
tốt hơn tí này nói chuyện có vẻ ổn hơn
Vân ông cũng có thể cho sạch so sánh với
chính cái video đầu tiên tôi dậy mấy ông
sao bây giờ thì mấy ông cũng sẽ
chị cũng sẽ thấy tôi khác cách cách nói
chuyện cũng như cái dậy rồi khác không ạ
Ừ đấy thì tôi nghĩ là mày ông phải đặt
mục tiêu là như thế và tôi nói à Cái
nhược điểm bạn thân là quá khứ tao sao Ờ
Mình có những cái nước điểm nhưng bản
thân
nó không tốt mà béo phải cải thiện dành
cho nó nó dễ trở thành quá khứ của ông
Thế là tôi nếu mà để tôi tự ty trúng
thưởng em tự ti quá khứ của tôi thì thay
thế bởi vì nó không tốt đẹp gì cả rất
nhiều cái để được như bây giờ
thế hả trình độ đa cấp tăng cao tốt
để chứng tỏ sắp lừa được mấy ông tôi sẽ
lừa tôi bảo rồi thầy của tôi hồi trước
đó là kiểu ngày nào cũng là Nhảy đi Nhảy
ạ với sinh viên à đi thực tập đi đi thực
tập đi đi tập hay lắm Vân ngày nào Nói
đi nói điều đấy rồi cùng sinh viên để
sau đi thực tập thật tốt về tâm lý học
đấy
cô sinh viên bớt sợ việc này sinh viên
cảm thấy nó dễ bình thường là bình
thường chẳng có gì cả cùng về sau sinh
viên đều đăng ký đi thuật thử tập thật à
Ở đấy có mưa cho một đa cấp rồi nè nhưng
mà đa cấp đấy có lỗi không đúng không
Ê mấy ông Thu Ca đa cấp về cơ bản có mùi
nó cấp không xấu về Việt Nam không phải
về Việt Nam nữa về nhiều người áp dụng
có ở bên ngoại có không phải nói nói
việc về Việt Nam nóng xấu không phải em
cho rằng nó bị Biến tấu với nhiều
đấy nhưng mà thực tế là
về cái mô hình nó vẫn là một mô hình nào
đó thì tốt Nó muốn mô hình sinh ra từ
trước gửi lâu rồi
anh không nói đa cấp tốt đâu nhá không
phải là lùi đâu mày ông vào bây giờ đâu
nhé
Chị nói là để mô hình 2 và bơ Giả sử tôi
có lùa mấy ông nữa thì tội lừa mày ông
đi làm tốt cho mấy ông chẳng được cái gì
nữa nói rồi chẳng được gì à nhưng gần
đây Đúng là tôi không từ chối các hang
động Nếu hard bảo là
có tiền hoa hồng của tôi Tôi từng nói
rồi tôi không lợi tôi không kiếm vui lợi
từ đấy nhưng bây là Nếu giả sử HR mà có
cho tôi cái gì đấy thôi sẽ nhận cho tôi
sẽ mua một cái khoa học hay một cái gì
đó rồi lại chia sẻ tài liệu Ông ấy ông
sau chứ Gần đây tôi thấy một cái khóa
học tôi từng mua rồi ra nó hơi bị cũ rồi
còn chưa kể là hôm trước tôi tìm lại
được cái mày cái đồng kim giao diện mà
hồi chơi từng mua Black phải đây cái
cách đây 35 35 34 năm nữa rồi
Ừ nó cũng rồi dùng bút chap 3 chẳng hạn
thế nên mỗi chap 425 mới như Cha bố nay
ăn gì gì đó rồi anh ra tôi sẽ không ý
nghĩa về sau có cái gì chưa xài được mấy
ông một là tôi tự chi chi tiền túi ra
hai chi bằng đúng tiền đấy có không thì
nếu là đương nhiên tiền đấy mà không
dùng được thì tôi sẽ lại tổ chức online
thôi Tôi nghĩ à
anh Thắng Thắng Tháng 10 này là tôi sẽ
vào trong Sài Gòn để mà tổ chức ở lai
này ờ tôi sẽ ở đây 2 tuần tổ chức
offline cho đầu tiên là cho anh em chưa
tim riêng đã sau đó tổ chức quy mô lớn
sẽ cho con đăng ký ta một lần nữa thì sẽ
là tổ chức riêng cho lớp mình dùng được
Lớp mình hay nhỉ nói chung vào kiểu để
cho Đấy lo cầu dạng cho anh em mình kiểu
có buổi đi riêng anh Tâm sự riêng giao
lưu ít người còn cái buổi giao lươn to
cái offline toi Nam mà chẳng nói chuyện
với nhau mấy đâu ông ạ này
để không ạ nghe rồi hứa như thế
còn cái chim của bất chấp 30 biết được
tác dụng trường hợp nào đấy là vui rồi à
ông Để ý kỹ thì tôi đã đổi tiêu đề
khi tôi còn là tách hẳn list ra riêng
rồi
Đây là một đồ ăn khác đồ án trước là đồ
ăn ở web môi giới việc làm nhưng mà do
là tiêu đề ngắn quá Tôi ghi sử dụng em
bối rối
thì gửi Vespa cấp ở lại được đây khi con
à con đồ ăn này sẽ thở ra đồ này không
không phải là là mình hôm nay mình bắt
đầu học đồ án này bỏ qua Đồ ăn kia mà do
là tôi có thông báo đấy Đó là do nhiều
nhóm bây giờ đang dùng ban chọn cái đề
tài về quản lý nhà trường mà thực sự là
cái phần phân tích lại là phần khó nhất
rồi Dùng từ khó nhất bởi thực sự là cái
thường là các leader các kiểu cá 10 có
kinh nghiệm rồi người ra làm phân tích
sau đỏ thì đưa tài liệu cho các bạn để
các bạn chỉ nuôi cố tình Nam thôi tính
năng thì đưa nhân vẫn có thể có cái khó
cái dễ nhưng mà cái đấy các bạn mò được
là mình hướng dẫn về sau được thì cho
kiểu gì đó là có cách để làm cái còn
việc phân tích mà các bạn tự mò và màu
sai thì về sau chỉ có đập cô đi làm lại
thôi chứ không thể nào mà từ một cái
phân tích size có thể về sau Cốc Thành
đúng được bởi vì nó liên quan đã có đây
nóng hoặc phân tích bắt buộc phải đúng
nên là hôm nay mình sẽ thấy dậy trước
các bạn về cách phân tích đồ họa cho nên
mới có bộ hôm nay
đấy vừa nãy có bạn hỏi với tiêu đề hôm
nay là cái gì thì nó là như thế Hôm nay
mình sẽ phân tích các bạn về thuốc gia
thì như tội từng nói tôi dựa trên kinh
nghiệm bản thân cũng như là tôi đã từng
làm cái trang web về rồi và nó theo hơi
bị thiên hướng một tí ở cho cái học viện
cũ của tôi nên là không biết là áp dụng
cho tất cả trường hợp được hay không
áp dụng Trường bạn không biết được 20
cái lờ việc à Chưa chắc nói chuyện đó
lắm Bởi vì tôi tôi bảo tôi học thêm môn
này 3 lần liền rồi nhưng nó vẫn như Như
đùa ấy em tôi sẽ Phân tích cách của tôi
nhưng mà tôi tin à Phân tích theo cách
gọi là dễ hiểu cho mấy ông Bởi vì tôi
cũng gọi là đến bây giờ công ty tôi vẫn
tự tin là tôi vẫn đang được động nó ra
bay thì ngồi làm và trình rửa nghĩa là
tôi có kinh nghiệm thực tế rồi chứ không
phải là Ừ tối khác với nhiều giáo viên
anh ở một chỗ đó là tổng kinh nghiệm
thực tế tôi tôi từng làm hàng sản phẩm
rồi đấy nó khác với nhiều giáo viên Bây
giờ chỉ lý thuyết suông đấy nên là tôi
tự tin là điểm đấy có nhiều người có thể
thậm chí ở Phân tích hai cân tôi cái gì
đó người đã từng kinh nghiệm thực tế hay
hơn gì đó nhưng lại không biết cách
thuyết trình Thế là tôi vừa ăn điểm hơn
mấy người đấy Nãy anh tôi vẫn mạnh mồm
được rồi đây đồng ngã nhưng mà nói thế
không phải Nếu mấy ông mà thấy tôi Thỉnh
thoảng tôi có sai sót gì mấy ông Cư
inbox riêng nhé chửi thẳng thế này hơi
ngại ông ấy mau riêng tôi sữa do nhé anh
ok chưa Em bây giờ mình sẽ đầu tiên
ở đầu tiên thì mình sẽ làm kể Phân tích
về cả trang web là tôi cái gì Hạt dog ra
cho gọi tử tế Ngoại Ô
ừ ừ
giáo viên cốt động ít lắm Xài vest không
biết cái đi bước nữa cùng trước tôi muốn
Cường đúng như ông thầy thầy thạc sĩ là
nó
ngồi gói xe không được hiểu là sẽ cho
xem quá quả Excel tôi Tôi ví dụ rồi nhá
ví dụ cực
dù có tên tôi
tên ông nọ nữa đây này như này đúng
không Thì ông ấy cậu gõ ngay hai này
xuống kéo như này xuống không được vì
người ta ra một mà không không biết giữ
control thể gọi ông kéo tận hai bác phát
nhà không được rồi rồi ông ấy không biết
làm cái nào võ một tai hại và Bố nằm
ngay ở Giận mấy chục đứa chán vậy
thạc sĩ
ga không có thể họ không chuyên dùng
excel không thể trách họ được vẫn như
trong nó buồn cười ông hiểu không sẽ
buồn cười và đặc biệt là cái đấy cái cơ
bản nhất mà ta đổ cái đầu tiên cho cái
đầu tiên mình phát hiện được hồi mà học
cách SEO ấy chứ nhưng mà không
một mình cưỡi ông hiểu không ạ
quái ông làm nó cậu khi mà thực hành
sông trông buồn cười làm ông bị cụt hứng
có thể lý giữa họ vẫn tốt có thể đâu Em
khẳng định hôm đấy tôi dậy thấy dậy thấy
đúng kiểu cức cức tài liệu do đọc chào
dậy đi cả mẹ tôi cũng
anh không biết nói gì thì cho mình trở
chán lắm thầy cô dạy chồng như thế thôi
không biết dạy trên trường nhà nhớ dậy
tôi hiểu đi hết giờ sợ cháu ạ
[âm nhạc]
Anh ở không Sao thở ra tôi nói thế nhá
sẵn mày ông ở đấy cậu mấy ông kém sao
hai đứa tên gì đó không sao
Ừ tôi không đánh giá một con người chỉ
vì người ta chỉ kém một tí gì gì đó có
rất nhiều mà bị hỏng một cái kiến thức
góc nào đó đã sửa tôi cũng sẽ có nhiều
cái tôi không biết nó cũng sẽ có người
cười thôi việc đấy nó bình thường nhưng
nhưng mà nhưng mà trông nó vẫn buồn cười
bởi vì a thầy ấy không phải lỗi chuyện
đấy nếu mà thấy rõ toàn diện mà chỉ bị
muỗi cái đấy thì chẳng ai chẳng anh tiền
đi cả thấy nấu từ đầu đến cuối là nó
buồn cười
là rực ăn chôm chôm còn gì ăn hả tay rồi
à quên quên quên bây giờ nhà chung học
tập trung lại bên này nhá bộ phim Gọi
những đối tượng là sử dụng trang web này
mình sẽ có đối tượng và chức năng đấy
Tân An tục đối tượng đi thì đây mình sẽ
có là
dòng vào này mình sẽ có theo các bạn thì
cái cái trang web học viện thôi 38 tập
trung tập trung vào bài hôm nay tôi muốn
mấy ông ngồi cùng phân tích cùng tôi cho
gọi là
nhập tâm mà Thì thì để nếu mày ông nhập
tâm nào thì mới ông sẽ thấy sẽ sẽ phải
thắc mắc thắc mắc nhiều cái và lúc này
tôi giải đáp được chọn mấy ông bởi vì
tôi không Tôi không thể nào tốn tận 23
buổi nữa chỉ dài về mỗi cái phân tích
lại được không ạ
cho tôi tôi sẽ phân tích cái buổi hôm
nay nhé Mấy ông cứ nghe rõ nha Hôm nay
tôi phân tích này có thể Mấy ông không
áp dụng với đề tài này nhưng mấy ông cứ
thử nghe đã để mấy ông suy nghĩ đã suy
nghĩ tốt mà đúng không này Đấy hôm nay
phân tích sau đó thế tôi lại tiếp tục
dậy cái đoán môi giới kia cho đến khi
xong thì thôi thì tôi mới gọi đùa này và
que đồ án này thì chưa chắc là tôi sẽ
cũng lại phân tích lại nữa đâu nên hôm
nay ở buổi phân tích gần như là khá chủ
chốt nghe mấy ông và Cái quan trọng là
mày không phải tập trung buổi phân tích
này và mấy ông hiểu qua về cách phân
tích để về sau mấy ông đi làm không có
ai dạy mày ông phân tích đâu Lúc đấy lại
quay ra hỏi mà
thực ra là sinh viên tôi thế đấy sinh
viên tôi để bây giờ đi làm rồi vẫn quay
ra hỏi
con gà vẫn được coi anh em Mà lúc đấy
thì mấy ông lại hơi bị phụ thuộc thời
gian của tôi bởi vì đây ví dụ ngay bây
giờ sau khi mà tôi dậy xong này có hai
sinh viên nữa lúc hẹn rồi lúc 10 giờ 10
rưỡi hỏi bà thôi này anh chuyện như thế
nghĩa là ám chỉ ở đội theo tôi rảnh thì
không có thời gian giúp mấy ông ấy chỉ
vì lúc đi học thì có đứa đi học vẫn nghe
tôi nhưng có đỡ đi học thì nó không được
học của tôi là ngã thì đấy một sự thiệt
thòi rồi nếu không đang có lợi thế điểm
mấy ông được học và được hỏi đúng không
học và hỏi mà là tạm được chung mà và có
vấn đề gì hỏi luôn
đầu tiên thì bây giờ tôi đang định hò
này ông nha đó là
ạ bây giờ với cái đồ án là một cái trang
web học viện tức là một trang web quản
lý nhà trường nó bao gồm là quản lý rất
nhiều cái thì theo ông có những đối
tượng sử dụng những nay là họ làm được
những cái gì trả lời nhà đầu tiên là đối
tượng là những ai đã
của người ta thì phân tích sao đấy Đấy
là lý do là có cái khái niệm là bia đây
tất cả beginer ý analytic Alice nó kiểu
phải đi phân tích thị trường phải đi
khảo sát thị trường để nó rút ra kết
luận là người dùng có những loại người
dùng nào và họ làm gì ở trên trang web
họ cần những cái gì để mình sẽ có bài
phân tích này
anh admin amin ở trường tôi gọi giáo vụ
giáo viên này
sinh viên này à
anh
khoa lớp thơ ca là đối tượng sử dụng
không phải khoa với lớp
Ừ đúng rồi sẽ gần như là chỉ có giáo vụ
giáo viên admin sinh viên Thực ra là có
nhiều nơi nó sẽ có thêm cả admin amin ở
đây lại mang nghĩa là cái người mà hiểu
biết về đa cấp ai hiểu biết để hệ thống
hỏa lực phía slna thích kiểu như thế thì
mà quản lý trang web like cái gì gió để
nó nó cũng sẽ người cấp quyền cho giáo
vụ Nếu cả vụ quên mật khẩu hay gì đó Bởi
vì Nằm cái có tính năng làm gì có tính
năng đăng ký giả vụ đâu bạn muốn là giáo
hội đen tôi hãy đăng ký hôm này không
nói có cái tính năng này đúng không Thì
ăn mình sẽ người quản lý bay và quản lý
máy tính năng nâng cao hơn gì đó
à à
Ừ
đúng rồi gọi sĩ sinead MIN cũng đúng
sẽ làm ở những gì giống như bạn kể vừa
nói thì nó sẽ có liên quan đến khóa khoa
khóa gì đó ở bên trường cũ của tôi nó sẽ
khái niệm là khóa và ngành đấy thì mình
sẽ có quản lý dùng tự quản lý rất là
chung chung nhờ tôi tạm dùng như thế đã
Tí về sau mở ngoặc ghi cụ thể quản lý
đây quản lý cái gì ạ Có lấy khóa này
quản lý
ở lớp này đúng ạ quản lý
thế mình sẽ phải quản lý ngành trước đi
Tại sao tí sẽ nói còn đến lớp này
ở Quản lý môn học
ở Quản lý sinh viên quản lý giáo viên
sinh viên ở ngoại ô
nữa là sử trong học viện này sẽ có thêm
quản lý gì nữa quản lý lịch thi đấu võ
giữa hai quản lý lịch thi nhưng mà trước
đấy thì ở trước đấy thì sẽ có khái niệm
là quản lý ở đây là quản lý
điểm danh điểm bởi vì theo trường cũ của
tôi sinh viên đủ điểm danh mới đủ điều
kiện thi mình sẽ quản lý điểm danh
và quản lý lịch thi I
ờ ờ học kỳ vậy
với cái chồng cũ của tôi thì không có
khái niệm học kỳ lắm Tuy là vẫn có vẫn
có đấy nhưng mà thực tế là nó không quan
trọng lắm của vì môn này họp xong nhảy
sáng muốn khác luôn nó không giống như
nhiều trường nhiều trường thì sẽ có tiến
chỉ thôi Các dạng này học kì này đã học
bao nhiêu môn và vật cũng trưởng cũ của
tôi không như thế Tôi sẽ làm để con mắt
kiểu như thế à
Ừ đúng rồi bạn khó chịu tiếng lấy đúng
không Tôi không được nghe ông ạ Tôi nhớ
Tôi thường ai tắt cái đấy đi rồi mà tôi
từng từng xem cách tắt vĩnh viễn nó cái
nó gọi là season
Sistar Sao ở đây này Ok season đâu rồi
chứ không phải lại Đợi tí nữa đi
bình thường có cái à
sự thay đổi season đây và nghỉ tí nhé
à à
khi đôi
bình thường mà tôi nhớ có cái xin sao ạ
anh ở đây để hoàng áo nhé
anh tóc hàng gửi đi
Âm Nhạc
Ừ đúng rồi rõ đang ở đây bình thường có
đây này
Vì thế tôi tắt ở trong cô bé vậy Tôi tạm
tắt làm đi theo cần dùng
à
hehe Nói chung là hồi trợ từng tôi từng
chị xem có cách để mà mình kiểu thích cứ
những tắt Hàn đi rồi vì bây giờ có thể
giả sử đối tác đồng á nhưng tắt máy đi
mưa lại nó lại nó lại mở lại lên thôi
nghe Hồi trước tôi phải xem cái để mà
thoát hẳn Cường nó đi
mà nghỉ à ở trường tôi nó không có điểm
trên cần lắm chỉ đường tôi là điểm danh
thì chia không thôi lại hồi trước nó thế
tôi sẽ làm theo phong cách kiểu Nga sẽ
có thể hơi Tôi bảo nó có thể hơi khác
với các trường các bạn một tí bởi vì ở
trường tôi còn không còn tín chỉ chứ
không có tín chỉ gì cả chỉ có à điểm
danh nha xong rồi đủ điều kiện để thi
thi này thì sẽ có lần một lần hai lần 2
trượt thì họp lại hãy tiền như thế này
và thi còn có khả thi lý thuyết đó thì
thực hành nữa
Ừ cái quản lý học phí thì tôi lại không
muốn thì em ấy ông ở đây vì thực ra tôi
trước vẫn chưa Tôi cũng không làm cái
đấy cái hợp được là cái này nó liên quan
tiền bạc thì tôi nghĩa thôi cứ bạn nè đó
về sau chị với ông Nếu ông say mới quay
tiên tôi chơi ở đâu mà tôi không chuyên
môn về bên đấy tôi sẽ không rảnh tôi sẽ
tạm bỏ qua bộ đấy quản lý giảng đường á
ra đường cái gì nhỉ Nó giống như kiểu
dạng là quản lý phòng học đúng không có
bên tôi trữ phòng học thôi nó không có
một cái ra luôn kìa lấy phòng học thì nó
lại một cái tố khác cơ mà lý phong lag
còn đi phòng học gì đó nó cái khác tôi
sẽ ở đây Tôi muốn tập trung vào bài toán
có người rồi bảo quản lý thi và mình sẽ
có thêm và quản lý điểm này lại như này
thôi
khóa biểu đây thử cái nào tôi gọi là
phân công
cô dạy học và nó sẽ nằm trước ở cái quản
lý điểm danh này Ừ nó cần nhiều thời
khóa biểu đấy nhưng mà nó sẽ khác một tí
về sau tôi dậy mấy ông ấy ông sẽ hiểu sẽ
khác nhưng mà
anh không Bây giờ tôi không chạy FPT
ừ ừ
ờ ờ
trường của tôi học viện về nghề nên
Thành A nó thường béo két chắc rằng có
rất nhiều trường nó giống như FPT này
vừa nãy thôi mới biết về VTC cũng dậy
của đây này hoặc là trường Hutech hoặc
Aptech gì đó cũng chạy như thế mày à
thống kê hai cái gì do nữa thì mình có
thể bổ sung trong ngoài sau nhờ tạm thời
nên này rất là đủ rồi giáo viên Thực ra
bây giờ mình hướng đến là giáo vụ trước
với giáo vụ đã gần như kiếm hết động
chạm khá nhiều thằng rồi còn Hóa giáo
viên thì ra nó chỉ tác động đến cách
tương đối và những thằng này thôi chứ nó
không thêm những ngày tháng này nó không
thêm cái tính năng gì riêng mà cần nhờ
chỉ tập trung và những động chạm và
những cái hoa này
tức là sao đây là những thực thể này
mình sẽ mình sẽ khuya thực thể này ông
nhớ không ạ Đây là những thực thể mình
sẽ làm như thế nào ạ Tôi sẽ về thôi Hình
như tôi cài phần mềm này rồi xin hết sẽ
mở cho người trên đấy
ờ ờ
à À quên này
ừ ừ tôi đang nghĩa là có khi em ở trên
này để tôi lưu lên Drive
ừ ừ
Ừ đợi tí nữa tí nữa đi đi học à chị nhỉ
Ừ cái nó lưu ở đâu đi sắp nghỉ chưa hình
dung được
khi sinh bé lý trị liệu và lập
sơ đồ thể hiện ở
à À đấy
mở ra một cái À cái nào đó đấy thôi
bỏ qua đi Bỏ qua tại mà lưu lại trên da
có một cái lưu lại trên máy cũng được
rồi tí thôi tổng lên cái hát mà nó xa
ở đầu tiên thì mình sẽ có là mình có
những cái thuật những cái đối tượng lớn
đã đúng không ạ Tư tưởng lớn
ở đây mình là
a
City ở đó nha
a nhớ nhá mày Ông vẫn phải nhớ ở thực
thể nó khác rồi bảng nhé em có bạn vẫn
gửi tôi chỗ nó là cái bảng
ờ ờ
anh tôi đi là Đạt đây đúng không ạ
chị sẽ có là giáo vũ trụ
giáo viên tốt
ừ ừ
ờ sinh viên
nó sao tại sao như thế với rõ ràng nó
phải sinh ra sau khóa lớp các thứ thứ
amin amin thì cũng thể mày ông thể cho
và cái riêng sau
Ừ đúng rồi phân tích là rất quan trọng
mà mày không phải hiểu ai hiểu gì à tôi
bảo rồi vẫn ít nôi ngồi giảm của cái hay
lắm và giảm có thể khó hiểu với ông nữa
ơi nếu không hiểu này thì thiệt mày ông
cũng bởi vì rõ ràng mà ông ngoài việc ở
ông là lập trình viên ông muốn cả đời
ông ngồi cốt ông nhờ Về sau phải lên cái
trước gì đó kiếm sẽ phải ngồi làm phân
tích các tưởng thì mày ông lúc đấy mày
ông mới ngồi học quá muộn lúc này mày
ông phải hiểu qua những cái mộng thường
như thế này Nói chung là tôi đã dậy thì
ông ấy Ông đồ bán là để không hiểu từ
đâu lên cuối là một cái phần mềm mà
ngoan số người mấy ông có thể thích
nhiều người thích nằm phân tích cái này
cực xôm về sau không thể không không
thích làm cốt nữa đấy nó chuyển sang cái
á khi chuyển sang làm viba này cũng làm
cái phân tích gì đó thậm chí lên làm lít
luôn được nghe về hơi điệu nhưng thực ra
lên 5 lít rồi rõ ràng người ta phân tích
mới là rất giỏi người ta tư duy rất là
tốt rồi mấy cái này ông hiểu
anh đấy đấy Mày cái này rất quan trọng
để ông ạ
thì đầu tiên mình mấy ông thấy Thực ra
tôi sắp xếp cái này Tại sao lại sắp xếp
theo như thế này rõ nào Phân công ở tôi
để xuống dưới được đóng bạn Nhưng rồi
đấy anh trên Tại sao vì rõ ràng là mấy
cái này nó đúng theo thứ tự là cần phải
sinh ra cái nào trước cái nào sau nếu
người tôi không Cái rõ phải xin nói
trước thế này phải xin nó trước thì mới
có mấy cái làm sau đây mình sẽ có là
chợ hoa
hai thí sinh sao nhé Vào lớp
ở khách sạn ở lớp phải sáu quá rồi ở
đây sẽ có mã đi
ở đây sẽ có mã mã khóa
Ừ thôi để tiếng Việt chưa tao mày ông dễ
hiểu nhé
một bài toán xảy ra như thế này
Anh ở trường tôi từng bị dính và không
biết được à Theo các bạn thì cách nào có
vẻ nó hợp bị hơn tôi sẽ làm nhà nhá với
với trường tôi thì trường tôi trường cũ
tôi nó sẽ có là một bên là học về quản
trị mạng một bên là bên lập trình một
bên với hack khủng hai cô mà một bên nữa
một hàng ở thằng phá mới hả hắn xây Kiểu
cái gì ạ thì
thì nó sẽ mấy ông Chị nghĩ à bên lập
trình sẽ chỉ học về bên môn lập trình
không ạ Không bên ngoài chị mạnh thì học
môn quản trị mạng nhưng mà không ra có
nhiều môn nó nó hoàn toàn là nó cả hai
bên cùng học nên thấy ra là môn của tôi
độc lập cái kính ảnh đấy tôi sẽ đầu tiên
tôi sẽ tạo các ngành được
anh như này
em
làm môn của tôi ở độc lập hình ảnh cơ
thế
này à
tin tức là sao Bây giờ giả sử làm thế
nào biết được cái lớp này học môn là
không ạ nhất là chúng ta sẽ có mã khóa
để biết được mã ngành để biết được là
lớp này thuộc ngành nào
một khóa của chúng tôi hoàn toàn thể
nhiều nhanh có thể có nhiều ngành này
thứ cũng chẳng quan trọng gì đấy nữa đấy
nhưng mà một lớp của tôi sẽ học ngành
nào đó và ngành đấy phải có những môn
nào Ví dụ giả sử ở đây có vài toán đấy
là là môn lập trình C em ạ À môn còn
muốn gọi nhập môn mạng đấy ạ nguyên liệu
môn mạng thì cả bên quản trị mạng cũng
học này cả lập trình cũng học này đấy
thế nên là tôi sẽ có mối quan hệ nào bên
này nó mối quan hệ nó
a menu to many
khi dùng hình ảnh dậy nha
à à
Ừ nếu vì ông ạ
Ừ Nếu khó hiểu cái gì thì hỏi luôn nhé
ừ ừ
a tiếp theo là môn rồi này giáo viên rồi
này sinh viên lại không ạ sinh viên ở
tôi luôn thuộc đỡ rồi anh sẽ có sinh
viên thế này sinh viên Tôi hiểu thì nó
chỉ có thuộc một lớp tại một thời điểm
thôi không có kiểu
anh một lúc hoặc tận hai lớp nhiều nơi
là một lớp thật 2 lớp
thì lớp từ mã ngành từ nhàng ra môn mà
đấy thì không cần mã môn không này
rất tiện lợi điểm đấy
ừ ừ
phân tích thì có vẻ trông dễ dễ mà gà
Lúc mà mày ông tự phân tích Từ dạo này
đang nhằng này bởi vì đến cái đoạn phân
công dạy học này bao gồm nhà này Phân
công nghệ IH
em heo mẹ ông thì phân công dạy học nó
sẽ nổi những Thảo thả hay tạo hẳn một
trang chủ thể riêng
chủ nhiệm giáo vụ sẽ quản lý hệ
à à
anh chỉ có giáo viên môn học là giao vụ
nữa
đây phân công dạy học nếu không trả lời
đấy nó thực thể hay là nó là mối quan hệ
giữa thằng nào đấy không ạ
ông thì họ có thể thực thể tên là cái gì
Huy nói chuẩn nhất kìa nó rồi mối quan
hệ giữa giáo viên môn và lớp
Tôi sẽ làm phân tích cây cỏ nhà chồng
hơi dị rồi mấy ông nghĩ nhưng mà khi nào
ra đây là đúng
không phải là một nhưng mà nó không được
gọi một cái thực thể gì cả tôi sẽ không
có thực thể tên là số khóa biểu đây nó
sẽ là như thế này tôi thường ai tạo Hàm
Dương Tôi sẽ tạo một cái cách riêng ở
đây này Tại sao như thế
thì
con sẽ có một cái này
đâu đấy
Em có nhớ tôi có cái bạn đấy
Hải vào con được ok ok
anh Alo ạ
à à
được
giáo viên này à
À mà đây sẽ là một buổi học
ê ê
cái đoạn này nó giải thích nó như thế
nào để tôi thử giải thích cho bé không
dễ hình dung nhé
Bây giờ tôi đưa câu hỏi cho mấy ông dễ
hình dung đi
ờ ờ
Ừ thì có mấy giáo viên giận
tại một thời điểm thì còn mấy giáo viên
dạy
viên không ạ thì nếu mà về sau mà có
giáo viên nào nó dậy hai giờ sử Giáo
viên Kiên nghỉ một giáo viên dạy thay
thì một môn Một lớp có bao nhiêu giáo
viên dạy
nữa
điểm đúng có một giáo viên nhưng mà Nếu
giả sử là
Ừ nếu mà về sau không Tôi đang nói bài
toán về sau giáo viên nào nghỉ thì có
giáo viên khác thay được không ạ
anh đúng không
Ừ chiều nay Méo phải hiểu nó như này nó
là một giáo viên
em dậy
một có thể nhớ buổi một buổi chiều mua
giáo viên đối ngoại nó sẽ mối quan hệ
giữa 1n đây và 11 ở đây nó như này này
I want to many nào
nhiều buổi họp đứng trước một buổi họp
chỉ có một giáo viên dạy đúng không Và
Nếu giả sử về sau có giáo viên nào đó
thay
có hai kiểu giáo viên này giả sử Giáo
viên này nguy hiểm ạ
áo kiểu trông đè nặng đúng không đó với
nghỉ thì thì hoàn toàn thể thay giáo
viên này một giáo viên mới đúng chứ tại
sao tự nhiên tôi về đề cập vụ đấy Ở đây
1 vì 2 cái hàng này Tại sao tôi phải
nhóm 2 hàng này một như thế này bởi vì
khi mà mới ông thích kể tao bây cái này
bây giờ từ cái sơ đồ này nhá ông Thử suy
là bây giờ tôi sẽ bạn này có mấy cột và
những cột nào là khóa chính à
về đến nhà mã đúng không Má Thôi tất cả
đều là mã Rốt cuộc thì bạn ngày hôm mấy
cột mà những con nào phá chính
ừ ừ
Anh không quan tâm Tên bạn là gì nhé Còn
dẫn
quên xử mất cái kia cái à
Ừ hóa chính là gì
chú ý nghĩa của chính giá tốt phải già
lại cha mẹ dặn lại với khóa chính luôn
Ừ đúng rồi có mã giáo viên Mã môn mà lớp
đúng không
em
tôi đặt chưa cả mã lớp đi bạn lớp mạng
môn mã giáo viên chấm dứt
đúng rồi bạn Châu Minh cho nói đúng chưa
Ờ Ờ nhưng mà đúng ở phía sau thôi có ba
cụt nó sẽ là mã lớp mã môn là quả chính
Đấy và mã Giáo viên sẽ không phải là
khóa chính hai cái thằng này phải vĩnh
như thế này
các mẫu khác đi lại như này Tại sao như
thế vừa nãy Vừa rồi tôi Còn nói là sử là
lớp lập trình cho Nhã học môn TP hạ nó
ghi là long em ạ Nhưng ở giả sự là vì
sau
à Vì sao đổi giáo viên không ạ thì không
thể làm à kiểu 2 giáo viên cũng dậy cùng
một lớp được lúc đấy sẽ thay thế cái mã
vào viên này là sự thay thế anh ạ Ở như
này sẽ người khác sẽ người thay thế Sẽ
không có chuyện mà cùng lớp cùng môn này
mà giáo viên khác cùng dậy đúng ạ Đấy
đấy do mà là một giáo viên này nếu mà
cột mã và viên cùng là khóa chính như
này 3 cột của một khóa chính thì rõ ra
có thể lặp lại được cả mạng giáo viên
của ngài và điều này đều sai của Vì như
vậy lại còn là phân tích đó là mại một
thời điểm chỉ có một giáo viên được cái
Dậy thôi nghĩa là khi giáo viên này bị
thay thế là phải xóa Rập soán vị giáo
viên cũ để thay thế còn giáo viên mới
hiểu ngay để em Duy để đăng ký vào cái
phần mềm điểm danh không lỗi gì đó trước
khi ông thêm món cuộc sao tốt tới nữa
tiếp theo đó là
em làm hai cột và Quá chính bởi vì
ở cùng cả lớp này hoàn toàn thể học một
môn khác Chẳng sao ạ đúng ạ Nó không bị
lỗi gì cả biết nếu hay cả hai cột cùng
họ chỉnh biết đấy còn tương tự thấy có
cột Mạnh mồm thế
các môn lớp pháp cũng thể học lập trình
một thì vẫn thể học muốn TP nhưng thưởng
ngoạn vẫn không gì sai cả chả đi ra đây
không ạ đây hai cột mày bắt ruồi gọi
chứng ra như thế và bẫy do nó sẽ vẽ theo
kiểu như này đối với tôi hiểu vẽ là kiểu
nhà thôi không biết rồi vãi chuẩn nó như
thế nào nhưng mà tôi hiểu là như thế này
em có mấy ông hiểu được hay không
chuyện với ông đấy thì đôi khi ở Tôi
thấy Vẽ sơ hợp lệ chúng ta phải tách
riêng ra theo thành tính năng như thế
này nếu sẽ dễ hình dung hơn đấy cứ thực
thể này tôi sẽ gọi thực thể nó liên quan
đến tính nào nó tính năng phân công dạy
học đây Còn nếu mà ông vẽ chung và cái
này thì ra tôi không biết bé ông sẽ vẽ
như nào ạ
anh Bởi vì mèo nếu thêm ông sẽ vẽ nối 3
tháng này với nhau này
gì và làm thế nào để không phân biệt
được hai thằng này nó hạ gia khóa chính
thằng này thoáng không phải chỉnh ở lại
thì ông sẽ vậy nha
anh đúng không
cái này tôi không biết được mà vẽ như
thế này nó đúng hay sai tôi bảo rồi nhé
nhưng chắc chắn bao tay mà như này nó sẽ
nó sẽ ổn hơn đúng không ạ Cái ra tới bên
này đã tự với chuẩn này thì từ đấy thì
nó sẽ có phải thực thì nó phải dị như
thế này cái và thực thể này sẽ nó không
phải thực thể mà nó là vẽ thực thể cho
kịch chức năng là phân công dạy học
tích được đến cái đoạn này ông làm tao
đây này ông ăn tiền rồi ông làm những
cái thằng khác nó dễ về sau ông cốt bọn
này nó dễ khi mở ra được cái đó bây còn
mù khi ông ra tao bây đâu Kiểu là vào
đây ông bảo là có thời khóa biểu đúng
không khó biểu của ông tố không biết
được mấy ông làm thiếu biểu của gì nhưng
mà ở trường tôi thử cái này có nhược
điểm thì ra cái này cũng có nhược điểm
đó là làm như thế này thì ông sẽ tự chủ
động nói giáo viên mà hôm nay em ông dậy
và thứ mấy thứ mấy ngày nào ngày nào chứ
không lưu lại trong đó tới bây gì cả để
nhược điểm còn nếu mà ông còn làm chuẩn
rồi ông lưu lại là cụ thể là là giáo
viên nào dậy thứ mấy thứ mấy về sau ông
sẽ khá là cốt nó sẽ khá mà khó dùng từ
khó vì nếu mà ông làm kiểu mã lớp vậy a
mã môn này mã bảo viên này
nếu Chắc chắn là béo không để lưu này
được như này Nếu bao lưu ngày đây bảng
giá sửa đây bạn sẽ có biểu nhé
bí
ngô lưu ngày ngày còn chết nữa ông quyết
thẳng luôn là giáo viên nào dậy ngày nào
thì thì
Ừ có tâm mà 20 Giáo viên xong rồi 20 lớp
à Xong rồi có tận nhà 20 môn thì sao rồi
sau đó nhỉ kết hợp với việc là dạy một
môn thì tầm mà
40 ngày à
Ừ ông lưu lần này bạn đi lượng mỗi sợi
mỗi phân công dạy học thì không trả hai
đứa làm thế này cả
ở đâu ạ
đứng nha ông có lưu lại điểm ra nhưng mà
không lưu lại ông ông sẽ lưu cái này vào
trang điểm với anh ấy chứ không không
đưa Phân công dạy học như thế đâu phân
công việc học ở Chị lưu ý ngắn gọn và ai
dạy môn thì lớp xì thôi
cùng lắm là ông lưu lại số buổi trong
này đã sửa dạy thứ mấy này thứ thứ hiểu
ngay sau hai phẩy 4,6 nha chẳng lại Tạm
thời như thế ông hệ lưu kiểu này sẽ dễ
rồi đấy cũng thể lưu lại hình ca chẳng
hạn cũng được đấy
mấy ngày không không không Tôi bảo xuân
công việc học không làm thuốc tạo thành
thế Đúng là cái bảng này chuẩn nó là
bảng điểm danh anh
ở bảng điểm danh thì ông Lê đúng như thế
này là chuẩn không cần phải nói ra cái
gì cả ông lưu ngay ở Chuẩn Đề ông ạ ông
sẽ dùng cái mã điểm ra ngoài để điểm
danh nữa đây Tôi sẽ dậy ông luôn tiện
thì nói luôn rồi cái điểm danh nhá điểm
danh đó ông ạ ông sẽ đến Ừ cái điểm danh
nó cũng đây tôi lại phải về thực thể
trước rồi mới ông sẽ hình dung ra được
đây nhanh không
mấy ông ở Liên quan mấy chục thể mà nó
sẽ vẽ hiệu như
có người làm tiếp đi điểm danh
chợ đêm nay ngày phải đến nay sinh viên
không ạ theo mày ông nó sẽ ngoan những
thực thể là
Em thấy có nhiều nhóm chọn cái hay lắm
bạn ơi Bác dạy nào
anh nói chung chung chống lại chúng
quan đến môn lớp ở sinh viên không ạ
thực tế là điểm danh nó
Ừ đúng rồi bạn kia nó chuẩn nhất cái rao
giảng viên lớp môn là sinh viên thế nó
mới chuẩn đấy nhưng con là giảng viên
nữa đấy bởi vì rõ ràng Vừa nãy có nói
liên quan vụ là tuy là mấy ông có thể từ
ngôn và lớp có thể suy ra được là giáo
viên nào đang dậy
Ừ nhưng mà bé đang dạy Còn nếu mà giáo
viên như như vậy nãy tôi nói đó là giả
sử tôi dại như về sau có một người dạy
thay ở Ngạn thì vẫn phải lưu lại mã Giáo
viên là người nào dạy thay tôi điểm danh
hộ thay thôi những cái ngày nào đó nếu
thành ra vẫn thể lưu lại giảng viên nữa
đấy thực tế là như thế nhé thực tế bào
da bay nó rất là dị ở như thế đấy thi À
mà cái thực tế đó là chuẩn nhất định đó
là ông không phải ông không đi lớp đâu
phóng lựu đạn sinh viên và ông điểm anh
sinh viên không điểm ngành cao lớp ấy
nói thẳng như thế ông điện anh sinh viên
mà ông điểm anh thì ở lớp nó không ai đi
đủ à Không điểm này nó sự sinh viên thôi
nhớ Chẳng qua là có nhắc đến lớp Tại sao
Bởi vì khi mà điểm danh một lần thì
không điểm danh cả lớp chứ không phải
điểm danh cho từng bạn sinh viên một
nghe câu ấy nó bị mâu thuẫn hơi khó hiểu
tí quá Tôi thử vẽ mày Ông ấy ông sẽ sẽ
thấy khó hiểu hơn tôi vẽ đâu
Ừ ông xã nha
sẽ có
một lần điểm danh một lần điểm danh
thì nó sẽ như này
I love
em biết
A và
A6 viện
con gà thiếu kiếm một cái nữa mà mày
không biết nó thằng này
A và đây là một buổi kém Danh
Á
và một buổi điểm danh mày sẽ điểm dành
cho một sinh viên như thế này
ở đó
à à
một sinh viên được bao nhiêu lần điểm
danh
nhiêu điểm
anh ạ
em phải dùng từ phải dùng câu hỏi như
thế nào nhỉ
Đầu tiên là một buổi điểm danh điểm danh
được bao nhiêu sinh viên đã nói chuẩn là
như thế Một buổi điện cho anh đêm nay
bao nhiêu sinh viên
à à
I am music
viên nhiều đúng không tiếp theo mùa sinh
viên thuộc
anh bao nhịn thuộc
Hà Nội dung từng em thụ bao nhiêu buổi
điểm danh
Ừ Ừ cũng đúng thuộc bao nhiêu tuổi điểm
danh cũng đúng nó vẫn là nhiều Đúng rồi
nó nhiều nhiều
à à
anh như nhiều đúng ạ sẽ là mối quan hệ
một nó này thôi
Thằng này là khóa chính nhưng mà ông
thấy bốn thằng này đều là khóa chính
nhưng mà cái cột mã ở đây Tôi vẫn tự
động tăng Tại sao bởi vì mối quan hệ này
là no no no
mua sinh viên sẽ được điểm danh 1 lần
cho 1 buổi học đúng như đã nói là một
sinh viên thuộc bao nhiêu buổi điểm danh
Em hãy phân biệt nhé mua sinh viên thuộc
bao nhiêu quả kinh doanh thuộc nhiều để
thuộc nhiều Buổi điểm danh không ạ Nó
vẫn là mối quan hệ chung giữa hàng này
nên là bạn chất vẫn phải tạo mã ở đây tự
động tăng để làm sao chúng ta sẽ có buổi
điểm danh chi tiếp
mình sẽ có mã điểm dàng
và mã sinh viên nó như này cơ Nó thằng
trung gian giữa hai hàng điểm danh và
sinh viên đây sẽ là Điểm danh ai đấy
mình kiểu nhà trong ngắn gọn này đã điểm
danh điểm danh đầy đúng không bốn hàng
ngày nó có thể là trong trường hợp này
của mã mình để tự động ta ngồi bốn
trường hợp Xong cho vào bài mình có thể
bốn thằng là Yoona cũng được 4 ngày vẫn
ôn ích nhé Không sao cả em chẳng qua nó
không phải bởi vì trong mãi queo thì chỉ
có cột tự động tăng mới được phép vào
khay chính thôi Hay vẫn là quá trí nhưng
vẫn tự động Tam nhờ cái 4 tháng này sẽ
cùng unique không được ăn chung Tại sao
cũng được phép chụp cái này thời gan ở
liên quan để cài trường cũ của tôi Đó là
một ngày một môn thì chỉ có
ung thư gan thằng giáo viên mày có thể
Ừ
đợi thì tôi bị nhầm đấy bạn này thì ra 1
giáo viên có thể không cần liên quan
trong trường hợp này giáo viên có thể là
trùng cũng được
Ừ đợi tí nhé á
ngày thằng giáo viên này phải ngoài đấy
nó pin ở ngoài
Ừ nó kêu cậu nghe nè
ngoài bị rõ ràng là giáo viên trong
trường hợp này nó để xem nhé
Anh ở trường cũ của tôi nhá một lợn 1
lớp 1 môn này chỉ học một chỉ được phép
học một ngày thôi mà chẳng có ca ca có
người cá sáng cao tối đa mà một ngày thì
có học ở trong một lần này điểm danh
thôi không có kiểu điểm dành cả sáng giờ
chiều gì đó đâu còn nếu mấy ông muốn làm
chia cho ca đấy thì sẽ thêm cả đấy thôi
cả đây dụ là ngày một này K1 thì sẽ ở
điểm danh kiểu nhà nhà đấy
khi mở ca này cũng sẽ là khóa chính
trong thường gặp như thế
cô giáo viên trong trường hợp này rồi
không quan trọng không quan trọng giáo
viên nào dạy không quan trọng vào viên
là dậy nên giáo viên ở đây nó sẽ tách ra
này vào viên này sẽ một giáo viên điểm
danh nhiều và một điểm danh trị của một
giáo viên họ sẽ là mối quan hệ ạ một
buổi đêm nay nhé chị xuống một giáo viên
sẽ là một quan hệ ạ
I want to many thôi
danh ngày lưu lại mã vào viên và nó
không phải là khóa chính để không ạ Cái
ở ngã ba thằng này sẽ là khùng u-nik
thôi thấy ở loạn không để mấy ông tự
phân tích cái này rồi phân tích được
Ừ đúng rồi một sinh viên có thể gian
tham gia nhiều Buổi học trong một ngày
nhưng mà một đối với trường cũ của tôi
thì một lớp 11 môn thì nó sẽ chỉ học môn
đấy một lần trong một ngày thôi Đây đang
nói à trường Đại học Nha trứng có cả
trường nhà trường cậu rằng là kiểu cấp 2
cấp 3 Thì đó thì nó học cả sáng cả chiều
Môn đây Lâm Tiểu thờ ông đi
không như thế nhá mà nếu mà như thế thì
ông thể thêm cái ca nữa cũng được không
sao cả
chợ hoa cào Tuyết đi tiếp tiếp có thể
thử vào được
à à
ngủ tại trên đấy mà trường Tôi ở sáng is
được học không thích ngủ
Ừ đấy nhưng đại khái thì nó sẽ như này
và chúng ta điểm danh chi tiết này còn
thiếu đó tình trạng đi học nữa không
phải cứ điểm nhanh cho vui mà tình trạng
đi học ở đây là sẽ là cậu có đi học hay
không gì đó Điều Muộn gì đó
ừ ừ
Ừ đúng rồi trường này thử gà nó hơi bị
có mang Thiên hướng là trường cũ tôi nói
như thế Trường Béo mới thể hơi khác một
tí nhờ tôi cũng chỉ dạy qua một cách
tính đồ thôi không không thể làm mật
khẩu áp dụng được có cả chưa được xanh
có cái phần mềm vào dụng tất cả trường
đều bây giờ cả thì dạy ngay để mày ông
hình dung được mà Mấy ông hoàn toàn thể
hiểu được cách phân tích Thôi để mẹ ông
có thể phân tích theo cách của ông
thế hả Làm nào để 3 cột cùng Munich cùng
lúc à Nhìn giống như khi mà ông ông ông
bình thường kia fire key thì ông sẽ cậu
mở ngoặc thôi
a family kiểu ngay soi cấu Cột nào của
nào đấy đúng không Thì unique nhỏ như
thế ông cũng bể unique kiểu như thế
không khác gì cả
khi nãy nick cảm 12 như này không khác
gì cả đâu nó sẽ tạo cả ba cái không được
cái chung cùng một lúc đấy nhưng mà sự
khác nhau ở với Uni của Fa Kitô từng nói
đó là hoa minki thì không được phép để
trống không có Mun còn unique thì được
ăn nuôi một lần đấy nè mấy ông phải cho
mấy cột này phải lót luôn để chắc chắn
là nó không được phép quá nôn chống nóng
ạ đấy
điểm danh chi tiết rồi đấy Thì từ đấy
mình sẽ có phần của điểm danh rồi này
Con quản lý lịch chi chi nữa Hôm trước
thì tôi định và ép cái lịch chi này cùng
trong cái á điểm danh cơ vì nó cũng lặp
đi học lại về mấy cái nhưng mà nhưng mà
không nó dị không một tí à
lại phân tích tiếp nhé đối với ông theo
ông thì cái lịch thi
Ừ thì nó liên quan đến mấy bà liên quan
đến mấy thực thể ở đây
lối thể chia ra đúng không
không thoáng chứ sẽ hơi choáng rồi
à à
á cái là mấy ông tôi bảo vừa rồi làm
thiết kế nhỏ ngày được ra nó khó mà theo
cậu thứ đều theo tuần theo kiểu phân
công dạy học theo tuần được nhưng mà Mấy
ông từ cái điểm danh này thì ông có thể
xem lại những cái ông lại điểm danh theo
tuần lại xem được bởi vì nó có cái ngay
đây Rẽ thì ông sẽ dùng cái thư viện
Canada rồi mà ông chỗ ghi đè lên và
những cái này nào kiểu gì đó thì sẽ hiển
thị những ngày đã được điểm danh tội
từng làm thì do trưởng trường tôi mà anh
kiểu như thế
có thể thao tội sẽ chạy mấy ông cái đấy
nếu mà kịp
bao nhiêu vàng cái này quan trọng là
kiểu ở mục đích của em lưu lại bảng làm
những cái gì nó chứ không quan trọng
việc
cần phải có bao nhiêu bạn mình thì đây
cả
cô giáo viên love moon sinh viên
Thấy không ngon ngày ở đây nữa một vỉ rõ
là lớp có mã ngành rồi không cần ngành
đấy này nó sẽ chỉ có bánh quần qua 4
tháng này với nhau thôi ông ạ thì mình
sẽ lại không thích tiếp
Ừ mình đây sẽ có
à à
khi phân tích Nicky Đây đúng
rồi ông ạ Đừng có điểm danh này nó sẽ
cũng nhậu dạng là là môn lớp vào ngày
đấy cũng có giáo viên kiểu nhà giáo viên
nào cũng được sinh viên kẹo ngày thì ra
tôi thấy hai thằng nó như nhau Nếu hồi
trước tôi định cục chung cái điểm danh
cái điều đáng ghét rồi về sau mới nhận
ra đó là có những lớp mà điểm danh thiếu
cái gì đó mình vẫn cho chi gà nó hơi bị
dị so với việc nghĩa nó không phụ thuộc
vào cái điểm danh ấy là sự dễ
à à
thế này ra nào chậu Hồi đấy tôi vẫn phải
tạo một cái bảng độc lập vành giêng là
mạng điện là bạn đề thi nhưng tôi nghĩa
là tôi hoàn toàn có được toàn bộ Cái này
sang ngọn Như Nhau Thôi nhá cái điểm
danh và vào lịch Kỳ nặng rất là giống
như nhau hôm ấy ông thể bỏ qua được tạm
nó nó giống sẽ kiểu Nga
đi đi Ừ thì đúng là đi thì nó sẽ liên
quan đến số buổi gạo dạng mày ông đi đủ
cậu Ví dụ ở trường của tôi sẽ là
không nhỉ Xem quá hai mươi phần trăm số
buổi không được Thiện ảnh cái gì đó nữa
Nếu sẽ bị cấm thi
ở những cái đấy là cái phần mềm của ông
Q Ước quy ước hại sóng cốt được kiểu
dạng về sau anh sẽ xuất ra được danh
sách những cái bạn nào
có thể là bị cấm thi và ông hoàn toàn hệ
cho phép phải thi hay không cái mấy ông
có thể làm sao Còn trước mắt thì bây giờ
sẽ cậu dạng mà kiểu thiết kế ra tao bây
sẽ cũng ngoan nào giống là kiểu lệch khi
này mà lớp mã môn này thi ngày nào này
giáo viên giáo viên ở đây sẽ là giáo
viên trông hoặc là giáo viên chấm thì
tùy ông ở trường cũ rồi sẽ giáo viên
trông cả chấm luôn lại dẫn Thế còn thích
cái ông thi rõ ở đây mã và viên trông và
mã rau a mã giáo viên chấm kiểu phân
biệt rõ ra cũng được
này Không hiểu thì thôi Không đấy Mà cậu
biết được à
em là người nào là người trông người nào
mới chấm kiểu như thế chồng này
em gửi cho nhé
một tí nữa ở trường cũ rồi nó sẽ ra mỗi
môn thì nó sẽ còn mà nó liên quan đến
kiểu kiểu thi của Vì ạ
Có môn thì sẽ chỉ học lý thuyết và chị
Chi lý thuyết không biết ở trường bé ông
mà như thế không nhưng mà trường tôi có
môn thi cả hai cảm nghĩ trước là thực
hành có môn chỉ thì Thiết có môn trị
thực hành tôi cũng sẽ làm cái tổng quát
kiểu ngựa nhé Nó sẽ là có thêm triệu thì
ở đây này Nó sẽ là này Tại sao lại thêm
cả như thế này bởi vì ạ trong cùng ngày
ông đấy Có cả thi cả hai kia hiện như
thế dụ cả thì lý thuyết và khả thi thực
hành theo kiểu như thế
à à
ấn vào đây là khi chi tiết thì cũng sẽ
có
em mãi mãi lịch thi đấu ngọn mã lực thi
mã sinh viên
em chuyển đơn giản thôi biết được sinh
viên nào thi thi vào ngày hôm nay
anh ra ông có thể thêm cột ở đây là kiểu
sinh viên này có đi thi không được gà
không quan trọng lắm vì kiểu gì
à quên cơn mưa cuối Ừ để xem tình trạng
thiệp
à à
lại tình trạng khi ấy để biết được sinh
viên này được phép khuya anh không hay
bị cấm thi hay cái gì đó nhưng thực ra
tôi nghĩa lưu lại đơn giản thì ông chỉ
cần lưu lại trong đây chính chi tiết thì
rõ ràng là sinh viên nào được vào danh
sách này là được phép đi rồi không quan
trọng để làm đó tương đối như thế nhá
tiếp theo nữa lại thì mới được cuối cùng
là cái đi học đấy Mày ở Phân tích cũng
nhanh phết mà không sang đâu Cái điểm
điểm thực là nó rất là dễ đĩa mình theo
ông liên quan những người nào
Không không không Mình sẽ dùng Tôi làm
vectơ rồi mà Faker tốt
à à
nhờ Magiê hỗ trợ sách data mà mình người
đào tạo Fate ta dễ ngon
anh Minh nhập cho cả khung cả không thời
gian mấy lạc được
những ngày à
giáo viên lại không làm người chấm nhưng
mà không phải người nhập điểm vào mà giá
vụ là người Nhật điểm ngân hàng ra là ờ
đúng rồi mình cái ràng buộc Face chứ
Ê tôi dậy mày ông qua cả đấy ông thể xem
lại cái bài
L'Oreal gần đây nhất tội dậy về feita ta
đấy à
khi
bé giáo vụ của tôi sẽ là người nhập điểm
vào mà thở ra điểm sẽ chỉ gần như liên
quan đến sinh viên và môn thôi nó không
liên quan đến á nó không liên quan đến
nữa lớp lắm nó không liên hoan lớp Tại
sao cứ ngờ vẫn còn chọn lớp để toàn bộ
sinh viên nhưng mà không quan tâm tới
được coi là
đã nhập điểm ở những đã nhập điểm là
những lớp nào mà chỉ quan tâm đến sinh
viên thôi Em Bằng điểm thực ra nó sẽ chỉ
ngắn gọn như này mình sẽ có mã môn mã
sinh viên
tại sao mấy ông để kĩ dùm mày đó mày ông
sẽ thấy là tôi Thỉnh thoảng tôi sẽ đặt
những cái tại xanh có những cái cột này
đến trước bộ này đến sau ra mà thường
mình phải mình thường lại quan trọng cái
thằng nào thì cứ để nó lên trước giống
như trong trường hợp này em ạ Quan trọng
hơn hàng nhà họ đang thằng nào nó sẽ lặp
lại nhiều hơn hoá mà lại cả ngày thì ít
lặp lại hơn thằng này ngày là lại rất
nhiều sẽ để đến trước này cái À mình sẽ
có điểm đấy
Ừ
nếu mà chỉ như này thì ra là không đúng
rồi lắm
Vì theo ông thì bạn điểm họ sẽ có những
cô nàng
khác mà Mấy ông nghỉ của tôi nó sẽ có
lần lần 1 lần 2
Bắc Bình
D3 thức a nói liên quan những kiểu kiểu
thi trước như vậy tôi nói sẽ hiểu khi
phải sẽ lần ảnh như này và đầy mới đi và
mình sẽ có bốn cột này là quá trình
anh có lằng nhằng nha
Ừ đúng rồi còn Ân Thi chứ có lần thi
Ừ để tao sẽ kiểu nhà tính Nhật lịch thi
này không phải có lần thì phải Ý em sao
nếu mà không lưu lại lần ở trong đây
lịch thi này thì bởi vì còn này thì ra
nó không chồng rồi không đi lại lần mình
sẽ phải đến lần
vì nó không nó không cần lưu lại lần ông
chưa gặp lại đó
thì tại sao không cần lưu lại lần nó
chiếc hộp này bởi vì a về sau tôi còn
chơi bài Hồi đấy ở trường câu còn chơi
cho dịp cơ gặp nộp thi cơ
mã lớp này Thực ra về sau nó còn sai cơ
lưu lại là ở đâu mà lớp thì vẫn vẫn vẫn
có những ý tôi gộp gộp thi hai lớp thì
cùng một lúc
Ừ nó dị rồi gặp thì cả hai lớp cùng lúc
để cho giáo viên trong Có nhàn hơn lính
khi thể lặp lại tạo này hai cái cốt để
mã lớp mạ lớp thì khác nhau thôi Còn mã
môn ngày kiểu thi có thể lặp lại giáo
viên các ạ Có dạng mà Bởi thiếu giáo
viên và anh thiếu phòng ấy mà kiểu có
mỗi vài ông thi lại xong rồi mày ông ấy
cùng thi cái môn mà lớp này sẽ thi thấy
là gộp luôn hai lớp thì cùng một lúc
cùng một giáo viên trong cùng giáo viên
chấm cái như thế nào hiểu gì đâu đấy Cái
bài toán đấy và cho anh có thể xảy ra
đấy đấy Tôi đang áp dụng thuế ở ngoài
thì thấy cái này thì có thể gặp lại
Ừ ok nhé Không cần lưu lại số lần đầu
thi lần 1 lần 2 đây thì rõ ràng cái lớp
khi lần 1 có thể ghép với những cái đứa
đã thi lại lần 2 cũng chẳng sao ạ anh
không Anh gọi điện
2 mà chưa thì họp lại
sẽ có mã môn này mà sinh viên kiểu thi
lầm mà đi như này đấy Bé toàn bộ đã tấm
bay của bên A cũng tương đồng đấy toàn
bộ tao bay ở bên là cái đồ án quản lý
học viện
chỉ tính riêng mình sẽ có lắm có những
bao nhiêu và
Ừ cái bạn này là bạn
vụ tấn công đúng không
số 8 9 10 11 12 13 gạt 13 mà
nhưng mà tôi vẫn mới chỉ ở mức tương đối
thôi
kia bảo lần 3 thôi mình nhớ nó thực tế
mà Nếu giả sử áp dụng giống như trường
cũ của tôi nó chỉ khi là một lần hai
thôi chị mấy ông có thể làm để cô đơn
giản hơn cho đỡ phức tạp về đoạn hiểu
chia lần này đấy tôi tôi đang chia sẻ
thực tế Đó là kiểu về sau nếu mà ông
muốn thống kê sinh viên nào đã đã kiểu
dạng là đã thi lần 1 qua lần 2 con trượt
2 á cậu chưa thi thì nói chung là đủ
kiểu đủ thể loại để mà về sau quyết định
chọn sinh viên đấy những sinh ra là được
tốt nghiệp sinh viên nào không ấy nếu
phải làm cả vụ đấy nhá Anh Nghĩa có cái
phần mềm gì Tôi từng nói có phần mềm
Không Phải Là Dạng như word kiểm nhập
vào in Đúng là những người nhập không
phải như thế Không ạ Mình sẽ nhập vào
sau đó từ đó thì phần mềm đưa kết luận
là sinh viên nào thiếu điểm môn nào sinh
viên nào Em chưa thi chiếu như nào vân
vân vân n thứ
bài hát bản quyền đường cũ gì tôi ở thằn
lằn phần mềm
trường có không mua lại phần mềm tôi
không bắt đền tôi không kiện thì thôi
chẳng có khái niệm để bản quyền đấy
ở siêu thị trường vẫn vào nào thuộc phần
mềm đấy tôi thực hiện thôi à
ý thì cái để làm đơn giản hơn nếu là sửa
là nếu mà ông làm thiệt cậu trường của
ông chỉ có thì hai lần cũng như tôi từng
là thì tối nghĩa cách đơn giản hơn nó sẽ
là kiểu ông có thể thẳng luôn Như này
lần 1 lý thuyết em ạ
e51
Hà Đông
vì vậy thể vẫn là kiểu gì nhé hiểu thì ở
đây sẽ lần một đây sẽ lần hai luôn Cái
này có thể mặc định là thể lùn
phát chống ngày sẽ dễ cho mình cục ai
Khi bữa nay sáng
ở nhà ông về xong thống kê ông chuyển
được thống kê cầu dạng là là lần hai lấy
toàn bộ lần một xong rồi đấy toàn bộ lần
2 cấp thiếu thứ rất là dễ
Ừ hôm đấy Tôi vừa dạy vừa đi vừa dạy vừa
cậu làm cho nhà trường kiểu dạng giáo
dục cần thêm tính năng gì thì ngồi phát
triển làm người chung mà không có kiểu
làm tù tì lắm có vài tháng dầu nghỉ hè
không đi Dậy thì làm chút Ý Còn không
thì vừa dậy vừa là các thứ Nói chung là
đại Khá gì à sẽ
anh cũng làm trong Trong vòng 2 năm
vừa làm vừa dục
để tập trung làm ra cũng không hẳn là
tập trung làm cả hai năm hai năm thì quá
dài nhưng mà tôi đã nghỉ ở trường 2 năm
rồi phần mềm
ở trường ấy bảo là không mua lại phần
mềm của tôi sẽ tự làm một mềm riêng để
trộm Chương Dung mà giờ cũng hơn 2 năm
rồi mà trường vẫn lại chưa làm nữa cái
phần mềm được chứng tỏ là mình tôi vẫn
hơn một đống trường có tuyển người làm
mềm mà nói nhưng mà người ta không phân
tích các bài toán này đâu đã hiểu gì
không mà phân tích cái này phải cái này
là cần người biết phân tích kết hợp với
cả biết bei tôi bảo đấy thì mà À tìm
hiểu thực sự là người dùng cần gì làm
cái gì này ra vẫn còn nhiều tính năng
nữa tôi chưa đề cập đâu vì cả tao tao
bây của tôi nó dài lắm không nằm như này
đâu tôi Cắt bớt một lý do mấy ông ngồi à
đều phải có không từng dùng từ để phải
có thì không hẳn như ăn chỉ là nếu là sử
ông làm mỗi kiểu dạng là quản lý điểm
thì mới ông có thể xóa cái phần quản lý
lịch học quản lý điểm danh quản lý chi
ông chỉ đơn giản mà cho giáo vụ và nhược
điểm của sinh viên thôi cũng được mà
Hoàng qua quản lý lịch học thôi cũng
được điểm danh có lấy lịch học thôi được
rồi này đấy hoặc quản lý lịch thi
ở ga quản lý lịch KIA hơi ít bị rưỡi này
một ông quản lý điểm sau đó về sau không
làm hệ thống kê Này quản lý Á
ưu điểm danh vừa và giảng và lịch học do
đó thì cho giáo viên vào điểm danh này
đấy Đã có rất nhiều thế nào để không làm
thôi và Lily chi cho thấy hơi ít thật họ
chẳng đoạn giữa Chẳng có gì cả đấy
ăn uống gì tôi
em có mưa không phải chọn đề tài này mà
để mà làm xong toàn bộ các tính năng rồi
về sau ông làm thống kê mà kiểu xuất ra
đồng cái gì đó có ý nghĩa cho người dùng
thì người dùng mới mỗi mới muốn dùng
phần mềm của ông ạ Chứ mày nhập nhập
nhập đủ thứ so với công lý hiển thị đúng
Cái này dùng vừa nhập trái nghĩa gì ngon
phần mềm giải phải giải quyết vấn đề đấy
Anh đang nói chung là nãy giờ vẫn thích
cũng phải cam Hạnh quyết rồi
ông tin là tôi muốn nhắc lại với ông một
phát nữa đó là hôm nay Thực ra tôi mới
rảnh Sáng nay tôi bắt đầu rảnh để ngồi
chấm kế đồ án của từng nhóm có vài Có
vài nhóm thì có vẻ đẩy lên tài liệu lên
link ít rồi nhưng mà và nhóm mình chưa
thì mình nhóm với cập nhật và tôi link
ít này cái thứ nhất thứ hai đó là tại
sao tại sao tôi lại bảo mấy ông gặp nào
đó tôi link ít nó bởi vì ghẹo tôi sẽ
dùng phần mềm được mà kéo hết toàn bộ
tài liệu mà ông về và tôi chấm theo từng
cái như thế này không thấy là tôi sẽ
chấm cho cậu nha sẽ mở lên nghe này cứ
chấm đấy
a cho ngày sáng ạ tôi bánh giá tôi nói
chung ở nó vừa lười thôi và nó tiện nữa
Thôi để tôi rẽ chấm tài liệu mấy không
giống hiểu thì tôi không ạ nghe mấy ông
có gì có đẩy hết lên như nhóm này là
chuẩn nhất Này đẩy vào trong thu bộ đau
của mình xong rồi để tôi chấm có tài
liệu có cả do chấm IO ở đây này cho các
thứ thứ này chấm qua được nhà mỗi tội
nhỏ hay phân tích sai tôi hôm nay tôi
phải làm 2 được sửa lại đây đây à
Hai và thứ hai đó là bởi ông tài liệu
của mấy ông cách làm chuẩn thì tôi ở
chia sẻ link like rồi đấy ông phải làm à
tài liệu nó tử tế một tí điểm là đây có
cái hướng dẫn rồi
Có ai hướng dẫn thì làm tài liệu Word
này không phải căn chỉnh bố cục cũng cả
Em cỡ chữ Thống Nhất này đang cả là dùng
Cài A justify để cắm đều hai bên có
nhiều nhóm viết tài liệu nó hơi bị dở
hơi tôi nghĩa là hơi bị trình bày hơi bị
xấu thì không phải sửa lại con lợn đấy
cho tôi tôi chưa chấm Tôi chưa chấm qua
về mấy ông viết như thế nào đó nha thử
cảm chưa thể đọc hết được nhưng mấy ông
cũng phải
Ừ Đúng rồi thử ta có nhiều ông thì làm
với cậu cách khác rồi làm chỗ kia thôi
Em về rồi à chiếu thiếu chứ thiếu một
bạn này nhé Còn thêm cái bảng là ngành
có môn
ngày họp Chi tiết nữa
đấy Ờ
đấy mày ông sửa Linh đi nha con bé đỡ
rảnh hơn một tí gọi thư giãn Tôi sẽ thử
lên topcv là tôi mua làm à
ở bài thi trắc nghiệm trang mấy ông cũng
thích ngồi ngắm tôi hôm trước mấy ông bà
thỉnh thoảng có muộn như thế cũng vui
rồi sẽ ngồi làm nhé
số tự nhiên có cái vụ mà
anh Skills ở đây tôi vừa mới xem mới
nghỉ
Ừ tôi sẽ ngồi làm hả ngôn ngữ không phải
ra đâu
xe máy kiểu này trung bình Có thể đây có
nhiều cái Tết có biết mày Ông thích tôi
làm nào đầu tiên tôi sẽ không làm HTML
Biết rồi Hỏi cầu gì đó
không làm đi dạy nữa
tớ sẽ có thể mai kia này p này
là gì nhỉ
khi phân tích dữ liệu Tôi Tôi định làm
bài này có nhưng mà cũng sợ lắm biết
được nó không giống như cái xanh kia nó
còn bảo sẽ hỏi cái gì nhìn có 15 câu hỏi
nhiều đáp án rồi Trình độ và trình độ
nâng cao cả à Dạ lắm tôi dậy thử mình
cái cơ bản cơ bản lĩnh nhà trước
anh trung bình này
à Tôi nghĩ à có cả cái thuyết trình là
do tiếp này tôi nghĩa tôi sẽ sửa cả mình
cái này chưa được mình để sai thì thì
cùng lắm mà mình kém giao tiếp đúng
không
Cũng được mà
hai kỹ năng văn phòng này ông ngồi ứng
tiền Excel II
đi theo mấy ông làm gì mình sẽ có thuyết
trình này giao tiếp này bỏ qua làm việc
nhóm đi
và chúc Việt Nam chúng ta ở không quen
làm việc nhóm chúng ta chiếm một mình à
khi phân tích dữ liệu đình sau này nâng
cao thông chú rể đó
P này mày quẹo này mà ông thích cái gì
không Tôi bảo vệ HTML với làm tự nhiên
mình bị trượt có ngu quá
mang tiếng em tìm giờ dễ
trước nhiều hôm trước do ung thư làm
nhiều our hôm nay thử sáng TP tí nhé có
nghĩa là một TP còn cơ bản
anh này cánh được giải được Nghĩ thế
không ngủ dậy à
em về chơi nha à
xe máy khuya về Apple server Còn nhiều
cái khác đấy để nói toàn bộ nó khác nhau
không biết trả lời nhà rồi
à à
I run đấy nhỉ
thi ấy có thể làm lại thấy ngon rồi đọc
mỗi ngày cuối ở đợ rẻ thôi
à nho có lỗi
được à
08 đúng rồi
8078 Dễ
xe lửa
chồng con như tất cả làng ăn nhiều mà
không bình tĩnh nhau mình đi nha Cái này
vẫn đụng này nếu thế sẽ tất cả rau má
nội
Cái gì đấy thích đúng à
anh em thích trả lời rồi đấy
bí mật mã làm gì Twitter input
3333 bằng full đảm bảo
an toàn đúng và hoạt động
a huấn lệnh vậy thôi hoạt động nó trách
nữa xe con mắt
ý an toàn về an toàn là gì
đang ở
35 đi có cơ sở rượu đâu vậy
à Hôm nay nào sau đây không chính xác
đây nhìn việc ngay cái này là của em nó
về ho gà của Will
anh em lại nốt wi-fi
cái này là mình ngoan hết đâu lại không
em nghĩ nhiều
hai thí sinh
Ừ nếu Xin chào Có một tại chở cha nó
Nhật
cho dễ
ở mức 10 câu cơ bản về trẻ con
anh không biết Tí cô gái nữa không
gầy trước đã phiên
tòa này một
ý nghĩa vụ rơi giỏi cái đấy chứ
những gì còn thiếu trong mã này ha
chồng mơ hồ
a single Man từ điển
hỗ trợ Hồng sữa step Chả liên quan xuất
phát ở đây ascii
3 kiểu biến Quốc kia không
Đạt mã sau đây lấy biến biến music
có gì kiểu đánh dấu xuống lòng những lỗi
à à
I listen
cho hai thằng ngày
synesthesia nè
à à khác nhau mỗi thế à ok
em cố tình cậu không xuống dòng để tiến
độ khó tăng rồi đó
ông trời cũng không biết chơi đấy
ở
biển siêu Toàn cục nào
cách chữa chứa chưa các thông tin a a
xe lửa
bộ quần áo pho này để chạy vĩnh viễn này
nó bằng ChuChu hết
ờ ờ Lỡ năm thì Black
khi exo Papa
cộng cái này sẽ tăng đến khi nào để năm
thì cứ ngỡ là bằng năm thì nó vẫn in
phát nữa
Ừ cái này enough + mày là phải cái này
mới đúng
Ừ bắt đầu hai rồi sao biết cái cốt ấy đi
khổ đọc Hả
Cái gì anh ở mỗi lần 12
sự hợp lý
phiên bản
à à
a.chu đúng 1
cả ngày say
ví dụ 3
a13
ở totu hiện loại Toán à
Ừ thôi anh làm thế thử Toán à
100 này -
à hài Quốc
a cộng 200 the
tính đóng gói thổi sáo
em
hỏi cái sao nộp luôn rồi nghỉ thôi coi
như cô ấy Chấp
à à
xe tải cho thận hay sai à
a public debt News
300 em đúng chứ ngắm tôi tôi đọc nhầm
nhọc nhằn lỗi tôi nói tôi nghe đúng đúng
tôi tưởng là kiểu đi tên Cái này gọi đến
thằng cao mà gọi điện bưu rồi Sai như là
cái này vết này rồi gọi một ạ một cái
Hàn public để gọi làm quay vết này vì tơ
nó cho Nội Nội Bài thôi nghĩ nhiều
Ông Trùm
khi nhận chứng chỉ à không biết được bao
nhiêu câu đúng à Tôi muốn xem Cô toán
trong anh không
chị sẽ không biết ở Khi hấp Thêm vừa
tán đúng không lửa
anh ta làm được
ở trong này uống trọng thuyết trình giao
tiếp này
Ừ cái này khó quá bỏ qua vừa hỏi cơ bản
con shit không làm được mấy cô toàn nâng
cao Hỏi với cậu thích phần chịu
máy kia này không Tôi thể kể cả tôi khi
được cái tôi không muốn đi thi HTML thôi
có giấy chứng nhận HB mà giờ mới xong cứ
kiểu đều nói đấy cũng đủ rồi
anh không
xe máy queo này thuyết trình giao tiếp
Ừ cái này đấy xấu cùng đi đấy
chú ý cho nó không Vip hiep sang công ty
này Tôi biết ít người cái gì về ông bảo
tôi thì tôi không biết ý nghĩa khi có
lệnh đi ừ
ý tứ gì sẽ là thằng tạo Vừa nãy tao cũng
nghĩ về anh nhìn còn nâng cao tâm bỏ qua
bốn trăm thì đi này nó sẽ là
15 phút là tư duy sáng tạo tại sao bốn
trăm chi ra đấy cả bốn năm trăm vị muốn
không chạm thì vuốt
a ghi hết đấy à
thuyết trình giao tiếp và mai kia ông
chơi mấy cái ngôn ngữ khác đâu sợ vừa
rồi hỏi toán với pp mày mà chả thấy
mình đang chịu
có ai bảo hiểm không tự nhiên đời nó hỏi
mấy cái Làm thế nào để cắt ảnh jean mềm
chết
ừ ừ
của em
ở bảng chọn
em ở trên này chat nhanh làm sao tạo
được
à mà có Này đây rồi Ờ
a tiếp theo DJ
chết lâu rồi
em kia thôi
Anh
giao tiếp này
những hình ảnh à
ừ ừ
nhanh em
ạ bấm bấm bấm bấm
anh không hiểu
khi uống trộm sư hết mấy bèo
Xin
chào mừng không
Em đùa thôi đúng không
chẳng có thì nói trước cơ mà
em hỏi cái gì nha
khi Rooney đâu xem
anh tự nhiên nó hỏi mình ghê gì đó chị
nhé
ở đấy thôi sẽ tạm tắt livestream rồi bà
mạnh một vấn đề à
Ê mày thi là có thể làm lại
em gửi ra đỡ chén hơn cái trên
MP3 school school Harry cân gì đấy chỉ
cho phép 6 tháng mà một lần
Ừ
cái gì đây Cái cá rô tiên khác biệt ở
a a
ở hệ thống quản lý không quan hệ không
quan hệ ra đâu
vì chúng không khác nhau không linh tinh
à à
ở ngựa đâm đấy
Anh bảo này nhá không phải biết rồi mà
tội thế
the Black Label
bừa đi
Pretty play 20 mỗi chữ Quay bên kia
lửa hai cái này xem à
có khác nhau gì
ừ ừ
Ừ cái thấy bổ If not edit It is it up
anh Bệnh hả Chợ Lớn sách chi cơ
à à
Ừ cái này máy cao nên chắc chắn nó sẽ
đến còn infomation này tôi nghĩa hết
khi chọn bừa xài thôi Susu cờ cũng đúng
sau chích cơ Tôi nhớ không lầm là xong
mà SQL Server biết được này đúng không
ở trong cơ sở dữ liệu hiện tại ạ
Ừ cái này thì nó là trong trong cả cái á
à
ra
Ừ cái này có thể với Ngon cũng đã tao
bây này cái này là trong đó tôi bê khác
đi nhá Nó nó bảng không phải là bảng hôn
như nó phải cái bảng nó bạn đây là tên
server rồi tên của một tay này vẫn đầy
trên mạng ấy đấy
em ở địa hiện tại ở đây chả cùng đã tới
bay đấy nói tao bay thì cha chị cái này
một cái này lấy tất cả tao bây trong
cùng cảm ơn sâu rồi luôn
à à
em ăn kết
anh xóa bàn của vợ ơi không còn đi chứ
cờ tướng bạn
để soạt Tân 11 Trên Cát Bà với các dòng
mùa khoa ngoại
em mình ngồi trăm kết là nó sẽ xóa cái
dòng bụt để mà không tự nói chung hợp nó
xóa
vi phạm mạng mới
cách tạo lại mới
Ừ đúng nhỉ Cũng có thể
ừ ừ
thế này sao không đúng đấy không dọn đi
Let's cơ liên kết
Em không biết cái này
ở các loại mới
Em có nhớ ăn kết thì như nó xóa luôn cả
nhà đất để sao là cái này
em phải tự đi lên đúng không
ở lại thôi Nhưng mà thực ra bây giờ
không biết được con là mình sai Đúng thì
đúng hết Cũng được lại cũng chẳng biết
được buồn
ừ ừ
thắc mắ
em hủy bài minhquang
em muốn kiểm tra lại bài qua không chịu
trả lời Câu 8 ẩn nộp bài
đúng anh tưởng như thế
à À không hai mươi phần trăm ở nhà không
phải đúng quá nữa đúng không vậy càng
đây ạ
chú
báo Huyền Sử dụng để tải dữ liệu 1 bảng
ừ ừ
anh không biết luôn nhớ Loan
ờ ờ
Ừ tôi không nhớ của chữ lâu cổ cái lừa
đấy nhớ là có chữ lắm
mẹ Quách Tuấn Du học nhưng mà cậu kể cả
loa rồi tôi biết là từ hôm đấy xem một
anh hack SQL injection nên biết từ loa
thôi Nhiều cái đao to búa lớn quá
ừ ừ
ở phiên bản án đúng về tham stem và về
bếp than thăm xem nhiều bay hơn không Bố
giờ chắc chắn Hamster không hiểu bài hơn
ừ ừ
300 câu Cả hai đều không lưu theo mùi
rượu chắc trả luôn
ờ ờ
ai là đúng nhỉ theo múi giờ tao cả không
thèm phải không theo mới gồm đúng nhỉ
múi giờ cũng đúng
cả các cột
sự của 1 bạn nhất định
cho xem
em có hàng này không nhỉ Không nghĩa có
hàng này không
thấy bồ con lùn
cho thuê bộ có lùn
Ừ nếu mà hồi chơi trò hiểu à
ở lại chơi với cái nào có từ Châu ở hàng
em
Hai vợ chồng nhà ở
khi mở tao mới trao nhỉ Ừ Thôi mình cứ
đánh đánh liều
ờ ờ
Ừ tôi chọn đấy Tôi nghĩ cái này cái đúng
nếu mà có hành này Alo hàm thì
hình ảnh
00002 phải có dấu ngoặc tròn cái làm sai
rồi sẽ là sâu
Anh Có Lâm for chạy bộ không cháu thấy
bố có luôn như thế này không có list
không Hollister
ừ ừ
phải để kiếm một cột có luôn không có
luôn đây không lại sẽ cho tất cả cuộc
đời
tạo view
anh em có phải có chữ a Pain and cũng
được
anh Bin
mk20 của banana
à à
em nhớ không cần bị điên em được nghỉ
nhờ trong máy queo không biết nhà em gọi
cho vợ rồi chứ không cần có được nhớ thế
Ở đấy từng tặng viên nhanh lắm
xe lửa
anh
ở đây có pin em nhắc lại này đi lên được
Ừ cái này cái gì
có dấu lớn hơn à Cái xanh đã
ở đâu biết cứ tưởng
em hỏi thử ấy
trong read code hot
ý nghĩa hình ảnh có ác trong nhé
em
có có nhỉ
anh không
khi ăn Nếu mà đặt tên như thế này mà là
cái này không có tên luôn Làm sao Hải
ờ ờ Làm thế nào bạn sẽ liệt kê toàn bộ
các bảng cơ sở liệu
Ừ ok bổ nhiệm không có hàm lý tao thôi
nghĩa không có lý gì đâu
sản xuất xế xe Ford đời chắc là sai đúng
không
anh sex ôn thi bộ
cùng mặc định
cho dễ
khi phát biểu cảm nghĩ của bạn
Những
bệnh nào hiện đọc phụ nữ
sử dụng Nam em gái
à à
[Tiếng cười]
tôi trên Apple server hơn không check
được không trách được
Á Châu
ở đâu thấy bồ sao phụ thấy bố sâu này
Ơ cái thằng đang làm lý tự Chắc chắn mà
à à
missile có Lâm
a saccharum không phải
I from art from một đại thiếu chấm com
OK Xong rồi à
ừ ừ
nói tôi biết được mà là tôi đã xa những
câu nào đúng không Cũng như là được
thiếu một điểm đã ngày 20 phần trăm nhở
Đúng vậy Đúng quá bán cũng chưa chắc qua
chứ không anh không trả mà
khách xài một câu uống à
xe lửa lửa lắm gì nữa lắm rồi tiền là
xấu chết cờ ngon
Có phải thế không
ô
ồ gì nhỉ và đúng rồi trăm kết nữa bạn
nhắc nhở nên chắc giờ lại mấy câu vừa
rồi và xem anh có biết thôi cùng lắm là
tí mà làm lại chuột
ở
quy mô data thể xuất sẵn data nhé
à à
phê nhá không liên quan để xóa phóng lại
tôi trả lời không sợ phòng ngoại này
à À đây đây không kích hoạt đia chỉ cơ
tôi chỉ nhi có trường hợp này thôi Nói
món đĩa chỉ cơ à thôi
à à
khi nghe tôi nhớ nó nó bay luôn cả các
Index nên tôi mới chọn lại cái tạp mới
kia nhà thôi chắc à liên quan cái đấy
Còn cái gì nhé chả nhớ còn gì nữa Làm
lại
ở Nông thôi Vả lại tôi nghĩa sau vài câu
dễ
đang làm gì vậy
đi làm lại
không vào chơi à
Vừa nãy hơn 100 + I
à à
Anh không ngờ xác là bài Thực ra nãy giờ
có thể trả trên mạng mà thôi không biết
tra chứ
ha ha
ti5 trong máy Quý Ông
tai5
em inbox
ở công công cụ lệnh
áo bóng đá nhỉ
anh alo không biết rồi không nghĩ cái
này chọn này
anh
không bi quan ấy nhỉ tự nhận ở dưới
ngoài những câu mình biết rồi đó ạ
à à
anh không khí tự bắt đầu kỳ tựa sẽ
Cô Gái Hội gay cái
tải Tập tin có sẵn sợ lại có đây
Trung hàng cái cũ
anh bình tĩnh nhảy à
bộ phim sex bao lâu thiếu do phải bỏ qua
ừ ừ
anh alo alo sai phạm
khi nãy
khi mua dặn backup khi kết à
ha ha
Ừ cái này tôi biết sao tôi biết nào thì
tôi vẫn mỗi từ này mới kia tôi không
chưa gặp vợ
tôi tưởng bà qua đây đi Kết đây chuyện
này rồi thấy ông có rất nhiều cái mình
không được học mà mình từng đọc có ai A
ha vậy Cái này cứ chọn đi tìm
có lợi thế Việc sử dụng bạn tạm thời
các bạn tạm thời bị xóa khi cơ sở khởi
động lại có thể thế kết xóa ngày là ngày
hơ hơ này không tiền án tiền học
à Anh nhầm đâu
luôn lần Ấn Độ
Ừ Thế beat
đã có 12 phút xong việc sau 12 câu 3
phút 62 câu
Ừ
ok các cơ sở liệu
đa số không đâu đấy
ạ sau db6 đá banh
Soda tay chống nắng
số tự nhiên có thêm chữ S nằm Tôi muốn
luôn á được
à à
anh ạ
Ừ ông nội là nhưng mà không thể tấu hài
lúc đang dậy được
hai lốp trắng kết chúng sự khác biệt mà
còn dùng đều dùng loại vừa nãy mình bất
tỉnh cái đoạn cầu bia thôi Âu kia vừa
nãy cái gì nhỉ Đấy liên quan đến cái gì
Ông ông nào Nhắc tôi lại phát nó là sự
khác biệt đi âu vừa nãy mình chọn cả hai
à đến tham với thăm xem mà không thì
thôi thử thử tra
đã được xóa bảo với cấu trúc
à à à à
số điện thoại nhé
à à
ô long tech
điểm của bằng các ký tự long tech ở đuôi
i5
anh Quý gái
tôi vẫn tự tin rồi gái
ông không rớt được thấy không rồi thế
nào được alo alo alo đấy
ở mấy cái chứ đâu không có rồi có gì nhé
từ lúc xa được ông đưa tôi ạ cậu dễ trẻ
con
ở đít hạn tôi cố tình thì lại để có
người khác đấy à
thấy có câu khác đúng không Nếu học hỏi
thêm đấy cố tình cả
à à
không có cái nó không có cài à
đề tài xây dựng đấy
Hay toàn bộ timestamp của mấy thằng này
đều không có utc ông đấy
ừ ừ
giờ tự nhiên thằng đi mà lên mấy giờ nó
buồn cười quá
có múi giờ
Cho tôi xem nhé á
cho
tất cả máy đều múi giờ không không mà
thấy nhớ thế
cái múi giờ với trong đấy chứ ý do là nó
không liên quan đến cái múi giờ 00 gì cả
tất cả mấy thằng này đều utc không hết
Nó không có cộng 7 nó cho rồi Cái cái
máy xuống ở đâu không cộng thêm bây giờ
ở đâu ông phải cấu hình mà nó nó nó mới
cậu không mặc định nó sẽ không hết chắc
thế
ở cái máy hàn vừa nãy là cái đâm cái gì
đó bỏ quay là mình không có tác dụng
Ừ cái bài phỏng vấn cho vui
em chưa chưa dùng đâu toàn gặp đầu
có bác sĩ nói ngon rồi đấy Nó không có ở
đây chắc sang chính trị nó không Có ghi
cậu đã chưa lần 1 nhé
vừa rồi nó bảo là còn một lượt trong
ngày dùng từ trong này nữa ngày hôm sau
thi lại được mà cho nó không thêm về dẫn
đã thi lệ trượt mấy lần trong đời đó
còn hai cái cuối nóng trọ nên là thuyết
trình giao tiếp vừa Ông bảo giao tiếp
với con gái đúng không để trả ông nói
chậm thuế chi nhà chọn nha anh cứ thi
sáng tạo
xe nâng cao
tự như đây mình bốn trăm rồi
e100 màu
rụng hết rồi nhỉ
Ừ nhưng mà nãy giờ cũng có Căng thẳng
giữa vui vẻ mà không
anh không Hà Tĩnh nhờ cái gì Nó hỏi mày
thể mình chưa vào nhìn thấy
anh chịu
Mình làm hai xong mình chuyển hướng sang
đa cấp có khả năng lãnh đạo tư duy phản
biện quản lý căng thẳng của bạn thân
bí quyết toán hơn hoàn cảnh khác nhau
cùng thử cùng tôi thử làm này nhá xem
chúng ta cùng quyết đàn ông nên tôi nghĩ
tới cái giỏi lắm đấy tôi tự tin đi
ừ ừ
cùng thì một ông làm à
ở thấy khó hơn
lắng nghe đặt câu hỏi thợ thông tin đưa
ra giải pháp tách ra tôi đọc cho mình
thì chả có uống nước tách trà Uống nước
này quá nghe
khi đặt câu hỏi đưa ra giải pháp à
nhau
Hai
người ngồi
đưa đi uống nước rồi tính sau
gần xong và sinh hạ đơn hoàn ra vấn đề
giống đó mình mãi luôn nhìn người khác
tinh thần tích cực cũng đúng Xem người
khác sai gì để mình khiển trách trở nôi
chuẩn đi đâu Xét
luôn xem mình có thể học nhìn khác và
giao tiếp Nhả tốt thôi
có hai giống như kiểu là công dân nghỉ à
giúp bạn thành công luôn được người khác
yêu quý
anh không nhận cái thằng làm mấy cái đấy
trắc nghiệm mày Chắc thấy được yêu vì
góp ý thẩm phán được luôn tươi cười học
cách nhận lắng nghe và câu hỏi rỡ như
tính phê bình khi có sai sót
em không có tự phê bình là chắc chắn nó
có bờ yêu mến
đấy giống như dưới đây Cái này ngược lại
của yêu yêu mến luôn
à à
anh luôn tươi cười
Ừ nó buồn mình cũng cười cậu ấy nhỉ góp
ý thẳng thắn Tôi tôi theo cả nhà này tôi
chỉ lắng nghe và không tôn trọng thôi
nhưng mà tôi gọi là nghe
anh
ta cái à
ii.quy trình lắng nghe trong giao tiếp
có từ than thở lúc nào
tập trung tham dự hiểu khi vừa đáp chưa
giỏi thế
Ừ chắc là giỏi nhất à
có sau nhà tôi muốn ăn thở với con chó
nhà tôi
ừ ừ
bạn là người lắng nghe trước nghiệp
a mắt nhìn thẳng mặt nó đưa mắt nhìn
thẳng
ốp lưng tượng ghé chân vắt chéo này cậu
sếp nơi nào phía trước ngay ổn à
chó trên ôtô ấy à
ý ngài muốn được lắng nghe không ạ
với người giao tiếp với mình
ở nhà yếu tố nào sau đây
bộ phim
anh dáng điệu cử chỉ trong
thế
này trộn lịch sự nhưng cái này không
liên quan đến giao tiếp
chào thân ái không Tôi nghĩ cái cho đủ
mấy cái để không ngoan ta tiếp là
cái này nói cụ thể hơn là kỹ năng mềm
mới đúng hơn kỹ năng gặp lắng nghe hiệu
quả sẽ giúp bạn điều gì trong quá trình
giao tiếp
anh thấu hiểu trong đi
sử dụng nhờ kiến thức sâu rộng của mình
là đúng kiểu này giống tôi được rồi vũ
trụ
họ đã nói không nghe à
à à
thì tại sao Việt đưa ra ý kiến phản hồi
trong giao tiếp lại quan trọng để chửi
mặt nó
để giúp người tham gia giao tiếp có thể
góp ý đồng ý và bác bọn thanh niên ế
tiêu cực quá
xe Honda giao tiếp để đồng ý hợp bác bỏ
thông điệp
anh như thế này
cho
so với bên anh em lốc học mình mà đầu
với dao tôi còn nói đấy em à trước mắt
là tháng 10 tổ chức tại Sài Gòn đã còn
không biết với Hà Nội thì tôi định là
bao giờ
anh có thể đi đi về offline có thể thế
không biết là
ừ ừ
đã rồi tính thế nào để tính không Mấy
ông không Tôi không muốn nhìn mặt mấy
ông mà béo muốn nhìn mà tôi đâu giao
tiếp không hiệu quả sẽ dẫn đến hậu quả
trứng nào đâm
khi đâm hoặc bị đâm
cho mình nghe nhau
chứ không phải đưa ạ
vì một người không làm theo ý bạn
Ừ để tạo ra một thông điệp hiệu quả
khi sử dụng từ địa phương dùng ngôn từ
khó hiểu tượng tiếng lắm bị coi như kiểu
tặng Ấn Độ Giáo Dục Công Dân nghĩa Tại
sao khi giao tiếp bạn nên tập trung vào
ngôn ngữ hành vi đó
Ừ thôi chị hãy Như
giao tiếp Tối văn chính sức khỏe
Tao phải đi vệ sinh
cũng đúng mà
số kiểu tập trung
Ô
Môi trường ồn ào
khi thiệp chúc những môi trường nào có
ảnh hưởng gì nếu bạn thực sự tập trung
ở giai đoạn giải mã thông điệp diễn ra
khi nào
từ lúc mà không thích ngủ ngon
khi nhận thông tin
à à
anh ạ
sau khi chia tay
hòa xã hội chủ nghĩa thì không
tôi làm đơn này thì lo và Vân thôi bây
giờ đòi quà những quà này tự bắt đầu từ
ngày hôm nay tôi đã bắt đầu hẹn họ ngày
nào đó toàn bộ số tài sản từ mà chúng
tôi đã có trong quá trình đấy thuộc về
tôi nữa đấy cưa đôi ta thử
Anh
giao tiếp văn bản lưu bãi
ừ ừ
sau khi tranh muốn nói chuyện này nó nói
chuyện trên giấy tờ chuyện với sư của
tôi
à à
tưởng phức tạp học về tôi nghĩa là phải
nên trực tiếp
em nghe đưa nhiều và họ cho nghỉ hợp lý
hơn
cấp bách phải báo xếp nhưng không thể
liên lạc được với sếp
A Gọi vợ sếp
anh tự xử lý công việc đó không làm nữa
không nào nữa
ừ ừ
Ừ cái túi nhựa có chịu thôi
Ừ Ông già mặt kiểu
anh buồn
anh hiểu Tại sao phải là người này có
hỏi
ừ ừ
Sơn à
vui nhỉ
ạ Bây giờ mới tắm xong mắt em
Anh đồng ý bùm đó dễ giận dễ
không làm gì đâu rồi được
có tư duy sáng tạo thôi mình cao lấy bỏ
qua cái phân tích dữ liệu nữa
ở trong có chữ Nghỉ 15 câu
anh nắm rõ thị trường cái này nó kiệm
bei
hai kỹ năng công nghệ nhiều nó lại đây
khi
tôi vừa Tôi vừa đọc về giúp cô gái bởi
rút một cái à
em làm vỡ thị trường
em biết làm này không nhỉ Mấy ông ạ
Ừ nó vẫn còn non đúng không Sao hôm nay
lễ hội hơi nhiều quá sao không sao đúng
không làm nhé Ừ tôi mai thứ cho tôi nghỉ
ở nhà bước tôi phải lên công ty
mệt mấy ông ngực
mà béo làm được anh đi con hẳn được ơi
nhớ mới làm nốt hôm nay thôi buổi ông
sau lôi cái này ra làm thì đỡ ốm Sao lôi
làm được nhưng mà làm do tính chất chính
là không chương trình này tôi nghĩ nằm
chán nó giống như cái giao tiếp lỗi đâu
tôi sẽ thử làm này chưa thì hôm nào làm
lại nha
giờ chị làm cơ bản
Em biết bây giờ cơ bản có còn sợ
ở đâu không phải một bước trong phân
tích dữ liệu thôi sao Ừ
thể sai với nó lọc dữ liệu
kiểm tra dữ liệu có này
ở tôi nghĩa làm sạch nó phải dùng từ
chọn lọc chứ không phải làm sạch từ
nghĩa thế Thực ra tôi học cái này rồi và
nó tôi từng học môn này nó tiếng Việt
nhưng mà thực ra tôi nhớ tiếng Anh cơ
slide tiếng Anh và tôi và tôi từng làm
cái forex Manager đó là tiếng Anh chị
ngoại tiếng Việt ngay đi
I Mục đích của with intelligent
à à
bài hát OS có lẽ Penny anh chưa lửa
À mà cho phép sử dụng để hội cho đỡ
quyết
200 bình tĩnh nha Có thể đúng hoặc sai
thôi Cái này trí tuệ mà à
a cho phép sử dụng dữ liệu để hỗ trợ đưa
ra quyết định
Âm Nhạc
khi dùng từ hỗ trợ mà hết
có mấy câu hỏi đúng thì mình có chả hiểu
gì xin ít để học tiếng Anh
thôi bảo rồi ông cứ đắm chìm vào trong
nó thì ông sẽ thấy kiểu làm quen thôi
những cái người à Đi ra nước ngoài họ
phải ép bạn thân học nó nhiều mình sẽ
quen ai rồi
khi phân tích hồi quy
Tôi chẳng biết cái từ ấy tôi sẽ ghép tra
cái này đâu có một cảnh như vậy à
em trả lời có không
Anh ở tỉnh các đặc điểm số mô hình hóa
cứu hộ không biết phân tích hồ cái gì
đấy vừa vậy mô hình hóa
lễ hội quy
kukuna Chắc thế
đã có không
ừ ừ
cơ hội chọn sai thôi rồi thấy nó với mày
cậu lại khóc nâng cao mà
quá trình thu thập và phân tích dữ liệu
theo chu kỳ trong một nghiên cứu đơn lẻ
được gọi là em quẹt mày Cái này đúng rồi
cậu phải học đúng với môn đấy lý thuyết
quá
ở
ngoài đời áp dụng với chứ còn từ tiếng
Việt này ạ
à à
cho em một chu kì có nghĩa Liên
ở đây theo bê tôi nghĩ có thể một ngày
thôi
Ông Hà ông Cửa Ông cười cũng không biết
đúng không
quy trình định lượng về định lượng tại
bremen biết mình không biết thiếu nhi
điểm Z là
[Tiếng cười]
vãi trường
kế toán à
quên hết toán rồi
10 chuyên toán ở đây không Alo mẫu số
điểm Z với Nghĩa Ấn Độ lệch chuẩn
anh không phát biểu về điểm số và phát
triển nghĩ ra đây
nhà phân phối này được sử dụng cho một
giả thuyết kiểm tra
ê ê
ở cuối từ này tiếng Việt à
Sợ rồi và mình anh này à
quay xứng
Emma viết đúng như thế nào dam dam lắm à
à à
không
cho ra Midi
khi có lệnh xlce đúng phải trả lời đấy
con này
Đây Rồi
cho dễ
tai nạn dễ như câu này thì sang bên em
khi học
anh ở lại qua thật này
I love trance
anh
alo lấy lại từ đây về nó
anh alo trái mà đúng không trái á không
lấy rồi trong trái từ đây đúng không
Đúng nói
dưới dễ nghỉ à
anh trực quan Hóa
a a boy I
đấy Sắp xếp sẽ
ừ ừ
đi chùa không mấy con gì
A gọi tôi rút lại Đấy mình nữa khó
Ừ anh thống kê liên quan đến sự phát
triển của thống kê
sự phân loại là
hệ thống kê tác dụng
à à
a true
các phương pháp thống kê cụ thể
anh không
vì vậy kinh tế đó tôi không nghĩ mày tế
à à
lá cây nhà nghỉ
Có ai như thằng Minh P
Em ơi nghỉ
đi
xe máy mấy câu hỏi cho biết chứ Có đúng
có sai được nốt thôi
chưa nhận được
chẳng hiểu cái gì đấy em bỏ qua mùa này
tưởng là mùa này mùa này là cái gì mùa
này nó cứ
300 mua này Các mẹ mua tôi thương đến lý
thuyết quá kể cả tôi được cái chứng
chứng chỉ của nó
Tôi có cái chứng chỉ của nó là đúng rồi
cái giống được đi đây mà bia chứ Tôi cứ
tưởng bei nó đi đây ra data đi ai thick
xong rồi kiếm thủ cái thứ
mô này kể cả tôi chứng chỉ của nó thôi
cũng không biết được ạ gọi lại gọi là
nhà nghỉ rồi nói thẳng là mình thi nhưng
mà mình làm mo ấy không Chứ chứ mình
được Chính trị thì mình cũng có cái gì
trong đầu đâu chịu
giới thiệu vui thì biết nó khó nâng cao
là như thế nào
Ừ thôi Bố hôm nay à
Ờ Ờ
nói chung là mày ông Cập nhật lại link
ít này thì bây giờ tôi chắc chuẩn bị ngủ
không nữa rồi mai thì cứ sáu mai tôi đã
được Dành cả ngày mai tôi sẽ không đi
chơi thì ngồi nhà chấm bài Chẳng mấy ông
ngồi kiểu thế này tôi tôi tôi tôi vừa
nãy vợ tôi vẫn tự nhủ Đó là tại sao mình
dậy là tôi không tự nhủ như thế là nhiều
người xung quanh tôi nói cậu mày dậy
miễn phí mà mày lại chăm chỉ thế thôi
không vâng vân tôi vẫn lên và oán rồi
các thứ Hữu
à à Nên giáo án hình dùng từ hơi tao
mượn và nhưng mà chúng mày tâm huyết thứ
mà tôi nói cho mấy ông có thể bọc như
tôi không bỏ cả như thế ý tôi nhỉ Mấy
ông có thể coi đây là miễn phí không có
gì ràng buộc người ông về bỏ bất cứ lúc
nào được nhờ tôi không coi Nó là một cái
thứ gì đó còn gì đam mê làm cho vui tôi
vẫn sẽ Dồn hết sức nghiêm túc và hết sức
vì nó nên là
tôi hi vọng không phải mỗi Ông mấy ông
mà về sau mình về buổi học này vẫn có
định Vẫn có giá trị để những người sau
vẫn phải học ai và Mai cho mấy ông bây
giờ hiện tại là tôi vẫn đang dạy cho cậu
là kèm trực tiếp được để đẻ mấy ông có
thắc mắc gì thì hỏi được chứ về sau hỏi
thì nó hơi bị như tôi bảo đấy là cái sau
hơi bị lệch giờ tôi bận rồi vì sao tôi
thấy bận cho những người sau đúng không
Thì nó phải mấy ông ấy không tiện để họp
em vẽ tranh thủ của họ bây giờ
em tranh thủ Bây giờ tôi chấm bài các
hơn nữa nhắc mình trưng bày Lười vãi
cho nên là mấy ông cậu cứ đăng hết mọi
thứ lên link ít nhá á
khi bé ông có cái vụ tài liệu ấy tôi
thấy mấy ông còn copy cái link tài liệu
vào trong lĩnh kỹ đấy nhóm này kiểu như
này thì mấy ông cũng phải
khi bé ông đừng làm kiểu này tạm tạm
chấp nhận ở copy nó ra Ra file đó rồi
đẩy lên để lên get nhé để mà tôi còn
chấm mấy ông copy rồi ngay tôi khó chấm
mấy ông thì du học có tận 26 nhóm số
nhóm nào mình phải copy có thứ nhảy đù
kiểu thì mới tìm được file mấy ông này
mà chấm thì mệt ra béo hiểu chấp nhận
với ông tại hết mọi thứ đến đít nhé thế
nhỉ À
em chỉ giận nói thôi
chào bạn nhé à